as a young kid i had big dreams of
becoming a concert violinist and
really poured every ounce of my being
into this pursuit from the time that i
was six years old
i saw that as my past present and future
and
i think it held me back
i would have benefited a lot from
having a more
malleable sense of self
[Music]
what is my version of my through line
like if you strip away all the
superficial features of a pursuit
what's left
that really ignites passion in me
[Music]
if there is a central theme to this
podcast and i think there is it is
transformation in other words the
mechanics of growth how to change and
what to do when life changes around us
well this subject matter also just so
happens to be the core expertise of
today's guest the delightful and highly
esteemed dr maya shunker dr shunker is a
cognitive neuroscientist as well as the
host of the podcast a slight change of
plans
she earned her postdoc in said
discipline from stanford as well as a
phd from oxford on a rhodes scholarship
and a ba from yale
in addition maya was a senior advisor in
the obama white house where she founded
and served as chair of the white house
behavioral science team
she also served as the first behavioral
science advisor to the united nations
and is currently google's global
director of behavioral economics now if
none of that is enough to impress you in
which case i don't know what's wrong
with you get this
maya entered juilliard at age nine and
was a private violin student of itsak
pearlman it's an incredible story i'll
let her tell it in the podcast
in the meantime just chew on that in any
event today we discuss her path from
violinist to the white house through a
behavioral science take on the nature of
change we talk about the power of
something called nudges as well as the
importance of
transparency
we discuss something called identity
foreclosure and we talk about the
downside of present mindedness as well
as many other very interesting topics as
you will soon see maya is just
absolutely amazing i think you're gonna
love this one so please make sure you
hit that subscribe button
and here we go me and dr maya shunker
welcome to the podcast studio i'm so
excited to talk to you yeah thanks so
much for having me before we even get
into anything uh i have to say
that uh
um
the most recent podcast that we just put
up is with scott barry kaufman yeah and
so i was emailing with him yesterday
like letting him know the show's up and
you know we're promoting it and people
are enjoying it and i was like by the
way i have maya coming in is there
anything i should you know that you
think would be cool to talk to her about
he was like oh my god we were classmates
at yale yeah what are the chances of
that he just sent me a message this
morning oh he did yeah he's wonderful
yeah that was an awesome comment you
guys were literally classmates i was
listening on my uh lyft drive over oh
cool conversation yeah he's great he's
great so i love that kind of synergy so
i feel like
um the timing is right for this i know
we had gone back and forth or i'd gone
back and forth with
somebody on your team about doing this a
while back and things were crazy i just
couldn't fit it in but i'm really
appreciative that you're making the time
to do this
um and i think
in thinking and trying to wrap my head
around kind of how to launch into this
with you
i mean first of all it's like a
privilege to share space with somebody
so
distinguished and accomplished
um
i'm going to do my best to not appear as
intimidated as i actually am
but in thinking about today
i'm reflecting on kind of the themes of
my podcast and and what you're all about
and the in the work that you do and the
podcast that you do
and really you know i have conversations
with all different kinds of people but
but if there is a central theme it's
transformation really like this inherent
power and potential energy that we all
have within ourselves to change our
lives with positive intention
so
the subject of change like what change
is the mechanics of change how we change
what happens when life change changes
around us
uh is so central to your work so why
don't we just begin with that like how
do you conceptualize change
yeah i mean i've never conceptualized it
the same way but i had some
early experiences with change that at
least
lit up
my
imagination
about what change could be and also just
piqued my my curiosity um and it was
unwanted change um so as a as a young
kid i had big dreams of becoming a
concert violinist and
really poured every ounce of my being
into this pursuit from the time that i
was six years old um so i
i feel like i define myself exclusively
uh you know first and foremost as a
violinist well tell the story about how
you discovered the violin and kind of
what happened it's really quite
remarkable yeah so my grandmother had
played indian classical violin and when
my mom had immigrated from india to this
country in the 70s she brought the
instrument along with her
and one day she went up to the attic and
took it down for me to see and she she
really had only meant to show me the
instrument it wasn't even playable it
was so large and out of tune and whatnot
um
but i was so taken by it there was
something about it that appealed to me
and so i very quickly asked
my mom to get me a pint-sized version of
my own and
she'd also introduced the violin to my
older three siblings who deemed it too
uncool for them so they went with a
clarinet trumpet and flute way cooler i
know way cooler right i mean you can see
where the reference point of coolness is
in the shutter family that we were
ranking classical music instruments
um but i yeah there was something
something about it
uh that i was clearly taken by and i
don't know what that was because when
you're six years old i mean it just some
it has to be a natural connection of
some kind
and um
my mom
to this day marvels at the fact that
while she
would need to motivate me to do other
things um
she never had to ask me to practice the
violin which was astonishing for her
because you know kind of rush home from
school and and pick it up and and go at
it and you're seven eight years old at
the time yeah and and i mean looking i'm
not sure today i have that kind of work
ethic that i had as a six-year-old but i
think it was just genuine
passion and so
my mom could very quickly see that okay
this is a kid with big dreams um but she
was also humbled by the fact that we had
no connections
into the classical music world i mean my
dad's a theoretical physics professor
my mom was a physics major like i come
from a family of scientists and while my
grandmother had played very
recreationally indian classical violins
certainly we had no connections in the
western classical scene right right
right but
i can interject a couple things first of
all
it's almost as if you're channeling your
grandmother through this passion on some
level yeah and beyond that perhaps like
uh some kind of past life thing like i
know you're a hardcore scientist but if
i don't you may wrestle at that but uh
you know the idea of a young person
cottoning on to something with such a
degree of passion at a young age is an
unusual and unique thing yeah i was very
emotionally close with my grandmother
um we would visit india for a long
for weeks and weeks and weeks on end in
the summer time and
i felt a kind of intimacy with her that
was very rare yeah um she was
big on prayer and meditation i remember
as a young kid i would sit next to her
and try to just imitate her
um her rituals and her chanting of the
various indian
hindu
slogans
and even the physical movements like
swaying back and forth you'd see me as a
little kid next to her trying to do all
those things so i i very much looked up
to her
she was kind of into medic meditation
before meditation was cool
um and so i i certainly had i certainly
felt a very deep emotional bond with my
grandmother this is my mom's mother um
but i don't know if i put two and two
together when it when it came to the
vote of course not yeah you know it's
more instinctual right and then with
respect to your parents both being
physicists
is not is not music like math plus
inspiration or math plus creativity like
there is a math piece to that right
absolutely yeah i think i mean
i don't know where the research stands
today but yeah there's certainly some
research showing um
certain connections between
the mathematical parts of our brains and
the musical parts um i imagine certainly
in the area of composition i mean
beethoven was clearly a brilliant
mathematician of sorts right i can't
compose for for my life but
yeah i mean i think they
i think i came from a family of musical
lovers but when it comes to translating
that into
concrete steps to help a child reach her
dreams that's where my mom was seeing
her limits right right
and um i think you know so quickly my
ambition surpassed what where she
thought it would and then all of a
sudden she's realizing okay i think we
need to get creative in this business
and so
i still remember so my big goal
was to get into the juilliard school of
music in new york so i grew up in
connecticut it's about two hours away by
car or train and um
i just had no shot because for the
longest time because i
my teacher
really nice guy had never taught anyone
before he was a grad student at a local
school of music and
i didn't build any of the technical
foundation
needed in music so i learned everything
by ear just play recordings and try to
kind of emulate what i was hearing with
my hands
and um
i literally had not learned how to play
a scale or an etude so for people who
are listening to this who are
well trained in classical music that's
going to sound completely nuts that i
started playing pieces before i built
any of the foundational elements
and so we kind of knew that i needed
some in with a teacher who had had more
experience who could kind of up level me
quickly
and so
my mom and i were in new york um i had
my violin with me we were walking by the
juilliard school
and she said
why don't we just go in why don't we
just go into the building it's like
you just go in she's like what's the
worst thing that can happen i'll tell
you one thing security guards are going
to escort us
out of here because we weren't invited
that's one thing that can happen mom
but these were back in the days when you
know
we were allowed to do such things and so
um we go inside and my mom strikes up a
conversation with a fellow student and
her mom the elevator and
we learned that she's she's studying
with a really renowned violin teacher
and my mom just asks you know would it
be okay if my daughter
meets your teacher if you just make a
brief introduction to her after your
lesson
and it's amazing to me still that
um people will say yes like the people
just be nice in this world and generous
people want to help they want to help
yeah were you dying of embarrassment
inside yeah oh my god i was absolutely
dying of embarrassment don't forget rich
like i
wasn't planning
on having to audition that day for a
total stranger right so i was definitely
like putting being put on the spot and
and thankfully i was practicing a lot so
i was relatively prepared for the moment
but you brought your violin with you
yeah we were i mean i was playing for
another
uh another audition that day and so i
had it with me and um
but i wasn't you know prepared to play
for juilliard teacher with a new piece
you're nine right yeah i was uh yeah i
was nine exactly
and yet but yet i think i inherited some
of my mom's fearlessness about the whole
thing so while i was totally embarrassed
about the walk into juilliard approach
clearly i had some of that fearlessness
in me because when i was given the
opportunity to play for the teacher i
wasn't running out of the room i was
firmly planting my feet in the ground
thinking this is my moment like this is
the moment it's come finally now you
have to seize it
and so
i played for him on the spot and
he accepted me into a summer program
that ended up changing my life because
it was a summer music festival boot camp
of sorts for me
and in you know five or so weeks he
brought me from and he said this after
the fact that when he first heard me he
thought i had no chance of getting into
juilliard i think he literally said he
just liked my personality so i was like
the personality card right i mean you're
you're you have a lot of humility around
this like you always you know push back
on the notion that you're some kind of
prodigy right yeah i i truly do not
believe i was prodigious and i don't say
that um with any sort of false humility
it's that i was actually exposed to real
prodigies so i saw
i saw what actually defines a prodigy
and i
i wasn't there but i'm fine with it like
i think that um
there were certain
there were certain advantages almost to
being having limits on your talent which
is that you spend more of your life just
living normal life and having
a diverse set of emotions that you can
bring into your music and i think while
you know so you know i had this boot
camp with this teacher who eventually
got me to the point where i did audition
for juilliard and i was accepted but my
technique trailed behind my musicality
for the entirety of my career
and i think that might be in but i think
there might have been an advantage to
that which is i think maybe something
that we're getting at together here
which is that um
when you have limits on your technical
abilities or your raw talent in certain
domains
your attention goes elsewhere and for me
it was
well i think my goal is just to produce
beautiful music mm-hmm and it just
became in that regard you're not held
captive by this incredible talent that
then drives your life i i know in my own
life
you know i've entered realms where i
certainly was nowhere near the most
talented but i also had a work capacity
to kind of narrow that talent deficit
gap and and i my sense is that when you
know you're not as talented as these
other people you have to shoulder the
responsibility of doing the work yeah
whereas people who are brimming with
talent have a different relationship
with process because they can always
fall back on the talent
yeah i think i mean
that definitely resonates with me in
other areas of my life but i
i'm not sure that it applied in the
music space and i'll tell you why which
is
i was not outworking my peers so that
was something that was pretty defining
in terms of what my childhood was like
versus the classmates that i had i i had
classmates
i remember one in particular shinseki
sato who is now a professional violinist
who lives in france or something and he
was practicing his age equivalent and i
know this because we were neighbors at
summer camp so i was next to him
his apartment and i could hear him
practicing eight hours a day nine hours
a day ten hours a day and
my mom was kind of like a couple hours
dude
that's it that's our max here in the
shunker family i want you having
other hobbies um you know i played
soccer when i was in elementary school i
did art classes tried out for the school
plays like she was really intent that i
have some kind of balance in my life and
so
i think that um
but but again i think that there are
various ways that
that balance can manifest right um
it did make me the least technically
strong player in my peer group
but i think it made me one of the
stronger
musical members of my peer group right
because i do feel like i had just more
to call upon in life to bring to my
you're living a richer life experience
so you have more
you have more to bring to the music to
personalize it and add your flair
because you're actually living your life
and not
just
sitting in practice a room practicing
yeah which is i mean it's such a lonely
sport you know i mean i think that's the
one thing
i don't miss about my violin years which
is
it's a very lonely enterprise when
you're a soloist
that's it's you and the bow and the
violin
in a room for hours
too i guess but i didn't even know that
i mean i've always thought of juilliard
as this conservancy that that is sort of
a collegiate experience i didn't even
know that they had programs outside of
that for younger people so yeah there's
a pre-college division right so that's
what you were in is that every day i
mean you're living in connecticut you
could have been going down to manhattan
every day no exactly so the pre-college
program demands that kids are enrolled
in some sort of full-time school
outside of it um for some kids though
it's homeschool because they took the
violin so seriously so they would i mean
i saw families torn apart over the these
musical ambitions right um two people
are living in a studio apartment in a
family in manhattan and then the other
two are based in seoul
um living all the way across the world
right to make to make things work and
ends meet and so
um
i was in just our publix elementary
school middle school high school
throughout and then saturday i would
have to wake up at 4 30 in the morning
my mom and i would take the metro north
train from connecticut to new york
again she says wild to her she wakes me
at 4 30 in the morning she's expecting
me to complain and instead i jump out of
bed you know and again i did not show
that enthusiasm for other things so this
is definitely special and then i would
participate in up to 10 hours of lessons
and classes the whole day and come home
super late at night that was my whole
saturday and then when i was a teenager
when i was 13
and itzhak perlman asked me to be his
private violin student things really
picked up and now i was traveling to new
york sometimes multiple times a week for
private lessons with him for studio
classes for he was teaching me chamber
music like
everything got i already thought it was
amped up and then
the dial just went way up i mean that's
so crazy explain for people who don't
know like who he is and what a legend he
is yeah um i mean arguably arguably the
best
the best violin player of all time and
what did he see in you you're so humble
about your you know skill and talent
like why did he choose you for this yeah
i mean it was an interesting situation
where my mom
had asked
our joint teacher so interestingly uh
dorothy delay was my one of my violin
teachers at the time who had also taught
pearlman so i was studying with her
and my mom
being the go-getter she is was like hey
do you think you know at some point maya
can just play one time for pearlman
almost as a fun life experience she's
got some serious mama bear energy
she really does and
but but never was tiger mommy so that's
that's the incredible thing right
um which is sometimes you see those two
traits coupled but she was both like
fearless but then also let us kids have
the freedom of choice in terms of what
things we cared about and wanted to do
she never pushed us to to do things we
didn't want to do right didn't have that
unhealthy relationship where she's
living not seriously through your
experience yeah definitely not i mean i
do know though that
part of her
ambition in
um exposing us for kids to as much as
she did i have two older brothers and
older sister is that growing up in india
you know she was encouraged to do well
in school and she occasionally would do
indian classical singing but outside of
that she was mostly
in the domain of domesticated duties and
i think she really wanted especially for
her girls
to have a richer palette of things from
which to choose and and your parents it
was an arranged marriage right like they
knew each other like 20 days or
something yeah they met on uh january
1st
and
they got married on january 21st so they
had a choice it was an arranged meeting
of sorts
but they both had to decide on january
1st the same day they met if they'd like
to get engaged
and um
i traced back i mean some of my mom's
fearlessness is just in her genes but
she also was put into sort of a training
boot camp of sorts when
you know she marries this guy that she
doesn't know 20 days later
she's a fifth grade teacher at the time
ends up uprooting her entire life and
moves to the united states with my dad
um into a little dorm room
in
in massachusetts and he's doing his
postdoc he's doing his postdoc in
physics and
um
she doesn't know a single person in this
country you know she's 21. and um has to
navigate this this new life that she has
and
she said part of her defense mechanisms
were to create a little army around her
that's one of the reasons she had four
kids was to create a sense of you know
she was so used to just 51 first cousins
so she's coming from this extremely
vibrant
social community
and then she is now living in a small
little dorm with just my dad
and so that was part of her way of
filling the void right but no so i so i
think my mom um
i think she was filled with a lot of
optimism
that
the united states offered so much
promise for her and she was going to
lean the fn
and that's what she did
with herself and and all of us yeah so
okay so
you're with pearl men yes what is that
experience like and what do you end up
learning from him beyond just you know
the technique of the violin yeah so so
for so i go and um
play for him and i think it's a one-time
thing and i am
not happy with the way that i've done so
i'm just like also that was around the
time that i was getting interested in
like mtv and trl and britney spears and
my brain was a little conflicted about
whether this classical music thing was
for me as that was my version of teenage
rebelliousness dare you i know how dare
i and so i don't know i don't know if i
was really practicing my uh at my peak
when it mattered well i'm sure you're
getting a pluses and everything no i
know i definitely wasn't um but i
but i remember i played for him and
again was not expecting much and then
he told
our joint teacher he said i i like to
take maya on as a private student
and that just knocked my socks off i
mean he had a he had a handful of
students at the time probably had four
students at the time
i just could not believe that i was one
of them mean
so what is that like what was that about
like what did he see in you
i asked i asked his wife candidly later
you know um because i i wanted to know
we met up for a coffee just a few years
ago in california and i was like
why did
why did it sock take me on out of all
the genius kids that were like running
around
because i know that technically i was
not that strong and she said
because he felt you had something to say
kind of hits on what we were talking
about right i think he
i think we had some sort of emotional
connection
just in our interactions and the way
that we were
what what i was saying to him through my
music for whatever reason touched him
which is
looking back actually like the highest
praise i could have gotten at his
musician i don't think i internalized it
at the time um because again i was at
all these insecurities but everything
else but
i think the thing that pearlman
you know perlman is a performer he he is
not he's not trained in pedagogy right
he wasn't trained to be a violin teacher
and so it's very interesting to see
that translation from like star
violinist to teacher i had no idea what
his approach was going to be
and
one thing that was so interesting about
his approach is that he didn't do a lot
of hand-holding
a lot of his work was trying to teach me
how to teach myself
which is really maddening in the moment
because you're thinking like dude you're
the genius right just tell me how to fix
this phrase tell me
um how to make this better and instead
the the lessons were filled with lines
of questioning well what do you want to
do with this phrase maya how do you want
this narrative arc to sound like how do
you want this narrative art to sound you
know
you get so frustrated twisting it into
some kind of zen cohen yeah but how
empowering it is empowering and you know
if you think about it
it's so pragmatic because a musician is
spending
99 of their time alone in a practice
room
so if you can teach the student to be
their own coach
to be their own teacher
now you've just increased your return on
investment
a thousand-fold you know because i'm
actually able to translate that into the
way that i approach my practice beyond
that though on that subject of having
something to say i mean ultimately
what distinguishes very good musicians
from the greatest is
those who have something to say it's not
the most technically skilled it's the
people who figure out how to inject it
with their soul or their message or
something that is unique to them that
elevates it beyond notes on a page
no i i think that's right and
i only had my experience
with music and you're 15. yeah it's like
how much did you actually have to say at
15. no exactly but this but but the idea
of identifying that potential like this
is somebody who has something to say and
will continue to have will continue to
develop the capacity
of that expression yeah and you know
thinking about it also rich i think
there was
i think there was a lightness of spirit
that i brought to lessons that might
have been unusual
because certainly i was in a pressure
cooker but it wasn't
for me it wasn't the end-all be-all in
the way that it was for other kids and
their families who had literally
sacrificed everything right
to be
within these walls and so i think
in addition to perlman connecting with
me musically i think
the fact we were able to like joke in
lessons
and i approached everything with a bit
of a reverence and
he was not too holy for me to jab at
make fun of like i just i think that
stuff matters too right like do i enjoy
my interactions with this person what a
gift so it wasn't like some kind of
black swan situation yeah no not at all
and i think um
looking back i just always had
rapport matters to me like it took me a
long time to realize like ah i'm
obsessed with human beings and human
connection and an emotional connection
and whatnot but
i felt like i cared much more about the
bond i was developing with any person i
was learning from that i was even about
how much better i became at the violin
it was so much more about the immediacy
of that personal connection and maybe
that's part of what he sensed which is
this is like a curious person
sometimes it translates into the violin
which is great but independently it's
just fun
to have someone who's curious and that i
have a rapport with right but the real
nugget of wisdom in that and we're going
to work our way up to it is this idea
that
you know the
the passion doesn't rest with the
vehicle for the passion you have to look
beneath the surface to find what's
driving it so in your case you had to
learn the hard way that it wasn't
necessarily the violin that you were
passionate about it was what the violin
allowed you to connect with yeah right
is that a fair way of describing
absolutely so i um
i mean i should learn this lesson the
hard way which is
against my own desires and will i i had
to stop playing the violin so
um started studying with pearl when i
was 13 and when i was 15 i attended his
summer music program
uh on shelter island in new york and i
remember it was a cold morning i think
in july and
i overstretched my finger on a single
note and i heard a popping sound
and i knew something bad had happened
but i kind of was in denial and i was
also the
recalcitrant impatient teenager that was
like i'm gonna will my way you know i'm
gonna work my way through this horrible
injury and
um
of course i didn't and even though i
tried to play through pain for months
and months uh on end and just fight my
way through eventually doctors told me i
could never play again and i just had to
listen
and so when that happened um
i mean i was just shattered and
shell-shocked and then
at a loss and i um
[Music]
like you said you're 15 right and so
you're not always maybe some people who
are really precocious are like this when
they're young like are very
philosophically minded but for me this
was a thing
that i loved doing and i wasn't fully
reflective about the role that it played
in my life i can make those reflections
now after the fact but at the time it
was just like
i am the violin i played the violin
that's it right and you were going to go
to conservancy and this was the life
plan and you'd invested a lot and
suddenly the rug gets pulled out from
underneath you
um on some level though very few 15 year
olds have a sense of what they want to
do with their life but yeah when you're
in that situation and your dream is
eradicated overnight it wasn't a
progressive injury right it was a
a sudden thing and you've gotta you're
you have to sit with that and figure out
what you're gonna do now yeah i mean
even convincing my parents that
conservatory was an option was a big
deal because i think for the longest
time they were thinking let's do the
liberal arts education please
you know a lot more security and also
um for both my parents who had had a
college experience i was very much on
the one track in india at the time you
choose your major at the outset and
that's what you study
my mom was so
uh enamored by the american college
system where you could take
chinese literature classes and then you
could also take a class on hinduism and
then you can take a math class like she
was just so excited by that and so
um and they were both working at yale
right like he's a professor there and
she was working in like student
relations yeah exactly and now now she
helps um students get
uh green cards to study to study in the
us so
she was so excited by the idea of having
us go to liberal arts schools and my
three older siblings had but i think
when pearlman took me on that was the
first moment where i felt my parents
were like okay yeah maybe it wasn't
maybe it wasn't the conservatives it
wasn't getting into juilliard at nine no
no because again to my point about the
fact that i absolutely was not a prodigy
like you would need to see the kind of
talent uh within those walls it is
remarkable
how amazing these kids are and so in the
same way that
you know when you're in sports at those
elite levels there's just so few spots
for people um the same is true in in in
music right it was just gonna be so hard
uh to actually to actually
make it and so
but yeah i think the conservatory path
was definitely
on definitely in the cards you know but
here we are a slight change of plans
yeah then i had my slight change of
plans and i remember thinking um i
expected to mourn the loss of the
instrument that's
natural i did not anticipate what it
would do to my self-structure like i did
not
anticipate
what a profound loss of identity i would
feel
um truly like the rugs pulled out from
underneath you and the thing that you've
defined yourself
by for so long is no longer existent i
mean
um
to this day my right shoulder slightly
elevated compared to my left because of
all the hours i spent playing the violin
and my spine is slightly curved my body
literally grew around the ergonomics of
the instrument so it was a part of me
today still right you know people talk
about like oh back in the day oh the
black my blackberry is like attached to
my hands like literally my body grew
around this thing and now i don't have
it anymore and
um
there there's a concept in cognitive
science called identity foreclosure
right and i highlighted that in my in my
notes actually because i i wanted to
spend some time on that this idea that
um we settle into we can settle into a
self-identity early and close ourselves
off from change
yeah and i really lesson in that i
absolutely fell prey to identity
foreclosure and didn't even know what it
was at the time um first and foremost a
violinist
i
saw that as my past present and future
and
um
i think it held me back
feeling that my identity was so fixed i
would have benefited a lot from
having a more malleable sense of self
and
attaching my identity to more stable
features of things rather than the thing
itself that's the biggest lesson that i
learned from all this which is but it's
also very natural we all do it totally
to some extent i am this i am my
business card i do this thing therefore
i am that yeah no i completely agree and
i think for me
um
what i learned over time and this hits
on in an earlier part of our our
conversation is
what was it about the violin that really
lit me up
and i think if you'd asked me to as a
kid i would have said i love the way it
sounds i love the way that i can craft
phrases i love the physical feeling of
the instrument
um
those were all true
and i had to grieve the loss of that
when i lost the violin but i think
if you stripped away all of the
physical components of playing it was
the fact that i could forge these really
deep emotional connections with people
in
the world not even just in the music
world in the world uh
with with my teachers with my classmates
um
i go on stage
in front of tons of people i've never
met before
and i have
i have the ability the potential to make
them feel something new to make them
feel something they've never felt before
and that's very
uh that's an intoxicating feeling that
kind of human connection when that's
gifted to you as a young person
and so
i found over the years this is fast
forwarding a lot but i found over the
years that
tying my identity to
the feature of the violin that i love
namely the ability to forge emotional
connections
has been a much more durable
steady state for me and something that's
i've been able that has been able to
persist over time and many career
changes it's the one through line that
exists
across
many many many different
sounding careers that i've had um but in
every
thing that i've ever chosen human
connection was at its core
prophets walk among us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years i've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share
those that we don't know who can teach
us something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing
and so i've dedicated my career to
tracking down the most compelling
prophets on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why i'm proud to announce the release of
my new book
voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration
and timeless wisdom that transpires each
week on the ritual podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying stand-alone work and
every copy comes with a chance of
winning our golden ticket sweepstakes
six golden tickets will be hidden within
a handful of books and will unlock a
treasure chest of cool gifts donated by
several of our sponsors see official
rules for details picking up this book
allows you to revisit the wisdom of your
favorite everyday prophets and
physically interact with the
life-changing ideas contained within
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
yeah it's such a beautiful pearl of
self-awareness to have that you know and
i couldn't help but reflect upon
my own life and
the slight changes of plans that i've
experienced
and the many pivots that i've made you
know i'm very much a late bloomer in in
really finding a groove that i love that
by the way
how you articulate like you know 41 42
45
yeah um
similar to you when i was a young person
it was swimming for me that was the
thing that i got up at 4 30 in the
morning every day to do without you know
having my parents to wake me up or
anything that took me to stanford and i
built an identity around that
and ultimately i ended up
leaving the team
uh a year when i my senior year so i
didn't swim my senior year and i
remember
mourning that loss like it was it was
like somebody had died because
my identity was so interwoven with
being this person who did this thing and
it took me many years before i could
realize that it wasn't necessarily the
swimming it was the community it was
like being part of a team and the
camaraderie and the tight-knit
relationships that we had where we were
all collectively working towards one
ambition yeah and having goals that you
can set that get you excited and now
all those things right
and then trying to overlay that onto
various professions didn't work and it
took me a long time to find something
that would give me that same sense of
purpose and direction and meaning yeah
no i think that's right and i i hope
that's helpful for the person listening
who is navigating an unwanted change or
even sometimes a will change that
surprises you and its impact and
destabilizes you in ways that you might
not have anticipated
to try to figure out
what is my version of my through line
like if you strip away all the
superficial features of a thing of a
pursuit
what's left
that really ignites passion in me
and um
it was funny i mean i've needed this
reminder every once in a while i
remember i was talking with a good
friend of mine
hyunsoo um this was you know
three years ago or so and i was just
feeling a dip in overall like life
motivation as we all do
and i was like i feel like i'm not
passionate about anything hyunsu
and he's like
but you're passionate about people and
i'm like that doesn't count it's not a
real passion
it's like oh wait no it is so sometimes
we also discredit
the things that come naturally to us
it's not as not falling into the realm
uh or into the domains of passion right
oh that doesn't count because it comes
naturally and i love it he's like well
take it from someone who's not
passionate about people that's what he
told me he's like take it from an
introvert who does not get the kind of
high you get from human connection to
tell you this is differentiating and you
should absolutely see that as a core
part of your identity that's so broad
because if you can really
like appreciate that passion you can
plug it into the world or into you know
any number of career paths yeah exactly
and and again i don't want to pretend
that i like had this all figured out
when i was younger it was no it was a
[ __ ] show when i was younger and i was
just really despondent and sad in morose
and probably not great company for a
while there when i first lost the violin
but ultimately you know i've landed in
this place where i have a slightly more
stable sense of self well in the in the
biopic about your life uh the the next
inflection point because you've never
been pulling this stephen pinker book
off the shelf right
yeah that's right the lifetime movie the
lifetime movie yeah it'll be an original
uh three people will watch it including
my parents um and so uh
yeah so the summer before college
again
probably not great company my loving
parents are like
we understand that your counterfactual
world involved touring in china maya but
instead the summer is going to be at
home with us
and so that's what i did and i was in
the basement just kind of perusing the
bookshelves and
i stumbled across a course book that my
sister had had in college and um called
the language instinct by stephen pinker
and i opened it and
again not expecting anything other than
like what is this i've never thought
about language before
and
it was
it was pulling the curtain back
on
an aspect of our minds that i had 1
million percent taken for granted and
never thought about before ever really
and revealed to me
how sophisticated the cognitive
machinery is that underlies our ability
to comprehend and produce language
and i
was in awe
i think that's that's the best word to
use to describe my reaction in that
moment it's like wow if this is what's
involved in language learning
what's involved in all the other stuff
like the high level decisions we make
the philosophical musings we have
falling in love
people who could do math like my dad you
know what's what's involved there
because i just found it to be
an incredibly like incredibly elegant
complex system and i was just in awe of
this organ that we all have and
it was a lightbulb moment for me it just
it just all we need at these moments of
inflection is just a seedling
just like a little something i can't say
that in that moment i was
100
like violin vibes everywhere oh my god i
found the replacement that's not how
things work
but
i was very excited yeah and i got my
hands on and the another reason why you
can't have that full
moment of intoxication is that you don't
know how this translates into anything
moving forward you don't know if you
have aptitude for it i didn't know that
at the time yale even had a cognitive
science program it was all new to me
right
but all i knew is i was really
interested and
what i was sensing in the same way that
my mom didn't have to tell me to
practice is that i started getting
putting
i started getting my hands on every
single book that existed in cognitive
science over the summer which is not
typically when i would be reading right
you know
because there wasn't school and so that
was unusual you know i was in the break
between senior year and college and you
know again the intellectual among us
will read books but i was that wasn't on
my couple reflections on this first of
all like you're
you know you're an insane you know
students
you know anybody who anybody at that age
who's going to spend their summer
vacation like you know pulling
neuroscience books out and digging into
them like makes you unique in and of
itself
yeah and obviously i'm nerdy yeah
and you you brushed it off when i said
you were getting a pluses but clearly
you're talented in the classroom and you
care about your you know your you must
have a
a significant degree of academic rigor
to have done all the things that you've
done um but i think the lesson here
is
you know when you were when you were
saying
that it wasn't like oh i knew how you
know this lightning moment where i knew
what my life would be it's really about
having the awareness and paying
attention to the things that excite you
and then you know just incrementally
giving them energy and like pulling that
thread and following it and i think that
plays into
the larger
topic of change and the power of these
nudges and things that you know are
central to the work that you do
and you know because people will always
say well i don't know what my passion is
and i feel like my life doesn't have
purpose and you know that when that
question was put to you you weren't even
consciously aware that people is what
excited you and i think everybody within
their blueprint has something that
excites them
but we're living so kind of detached
from our
our higher selves if you you know
however you want to characterize it that
that we're not present with what's
actually happening in our life and when
we have those moments i think a lot of
people allow them to pass and they
aren't given the energy that perhaps
they deserve had they been more
consciously aware of what was happening
i love what you just said because i
think that i think that was exactly
right in the case of the book
um
the book was necessary but not
sufficient for me to eventually land a
career as a cognitive scientist and i
think the translation piece is sometimes
where people get lost
and so i remember
okay i'm finding this topic interesting
so i start doing my homework look into
the yale course book i realize there's
actually this new program called the
cognitive science major it's
interdisciplinary
you take classes in a bunch of different
areas
neuroscience linguistics philosophy
psychology computer science biology
and you study the brain but you study it
from all of these different vantage
points and i see that it's like an
admissions only major and don't forget i
am having a lot of imposter syndrome
right now because i believe i've gotten
into yale because i'm a violinist and
now i'm no longer a violinist so you had
already been accepted to yale but you
hadn't declared a major i had to declare
the majority exactly and so um
i
yeah and i and i i think i think given
the timing i already the violin was
already off the table by the time i even
applied
so you were feeling like but i always
fraud because just but you thought
violin was what helped you get get in oh
100 and i thought i mean certainly when
i was imagining going to a liberal arts
college it was going to be
with the idea of majoring in music
obviously
performance right that was going to be
performance studies whatever it is that
was going to be my my thing
but i certainly felt like oh that was
the reason i got in and so i definitely
felt imposter syndrome for sure um
and so
so i learn it's admissions only and then
i'm and then i feel nervous um but i
still remember
that
in the same way that my mom had this
kind of entrepreneurial
i'm gonna do everything i possibly can
to stack the cards in my favor in my
daughter's favor
i had that mindset and i continue to
have that mindset
with just about everything else that i
take on
so when i decided that i wanted to be a
cogsin major i remember i learned in my
pre-orientation program
um that there was a
non-human primate cognition lab
i think this is actually how scott
and i i think we might have taken this
monkey class together um
but i i showed up for the first day of
the monkey lab which was an admissions
only class and
the room was overflowing
with people there were probably 40
students in there for
a handful of slots
and most of them were upperclassmen so i
was the lowly freshman in the room that
was trying to to get into this class and
so my chances were very small but there
was an application form
and i was like i'm going to make this
the best damn application this professor
has also you're like everything it
worked out with juilliard it's like why
not right yeah there's no security
guards involved in the case of an
application so i remember i wrote down
on the application form um
i will take the like 6 a.m shifts on
saturday mornings in new haven i
remember at that point my parents had
intervened and they were like it's not
safe we need to protect your safety as
our child over this monkey lab and you
know like
lori i will do anything and everything
to get in this class you'd have my
unborn children like i was willing to
offer everything up to try to get into
this course
and this professor laurie santos she's
like a happiness guru now right um and
she her podcast is with pushkin yeah
exactly she's amazing she's played a
critical role in my life ever since this
moment by the way it's a constant it's
incredible yeah i'd love to have her on
the show as well but it's hilarious that
there's scott there's lori there's you
now you all have podcasts
what is going on the cognitive
scientists prevail
um yeah i know i represent that makes me
very happy um but i
laurie took a chance on me and she i was
the only freshman that she accepted into
the class
i thought at the time by the way it was
because i showed so much enthusiasm on
my application and i and the pros was
perfect she later told me that i was the
only one willing to sign up for the
unpopular spots
so that's why she took me on she has
that happiness class right yeah she's
written about and that's the one that
everyone's claiming to get into yeah
exactly and so laurie was my laurie
zombie since i was 17 she helped
facilitate a
a big pivot in my life because um
she's the one who helped me make that
transition i remember my dad at the time
told me if you're feeling lost find
someone you admire
and then try to reverse engineer how
they got from point a to point b and
laurie was that person for me i really
admired her um
i liked how she was as a teacher i liked
how she was as a person i liked how she
was as an intellectual who was like
brimming with ideas and curiosity and so
i tried to like bring myself close you
know and um she became a mentor and a
friend very quickly and it was because
of that admissions ticket to the monkey
lab that in undergrad i got full
exposure to what it meant to be
a scientist to actually run
novel experiments and to generate data
and to make new discoveries or not make
new discoveries which is often the case
in science and it's discouraging which
is one of the reasons i eventually left
at the field but um
i was so grateful for that exposure
because it meant that i could actually
translate this early seedling of an idea
into something concrete and you know
eventually got my phd and my postdoc in
these areas right right i mean you you
brush over that but
basically you you complete yale you get
this rhodes scholarship to go to oxford
where you continue your studies you get
your phd and then you do a postdoc at
stanford right
was andrew huberman at stanford when you
were there i think so the hubermann lab
yeah yeah he's got a podcast too
i think that actually is more
representative of the fact that everyone
has a podcast rather than a vm but there
is something about college
neuroscientists and podcasts yeah maybe
yeah well i think that's great because
we i think um
any show that tries to bridge the gap
between
you know science and popular discourse
is great i think it's fantastic the
translation of science and the fact that
so many people
are enjoying that content is very
encouraging right like this is hard
science and
it's a two hour basically lecture about
the brain and
millions of people are like tuning in
for this
free content and i think that's a
beautiful i think it's beautiful too and
you know we'll talk more about a slight
change of plans later but
uh in addition to the the narrative
stories that i have my guests come on
and share which are these very personal
life stories we have
science expert episodes with people like
adam grant and katie milkman and annie
duke talking about the science of
quitting and um angela duckworth talking
about grit and those episodes are so
popular yeah people love learning about
the science of change that is so
heartening i did not know at the outset
how those episodes would perform and yet
people love them so the the most popular
episodes on this show tend to be the
hard scientists i mean adam came on and
that was you know hugely popular yeah
people love him and he's such a great
communicator he is yeah there are
there's hard science but then there are
i think the sweet spot is is the
scientists who have such a command over
the science and have this facility for
communicating very complex ideas in a
way that the audience can
digest it and understand it without
feeling pandered to like that without
the condescension that you typically
would see yeah you know this is a
this is a skill in an area that i am
actually deeply passionate about and
many of my former roles have required
translating science into
uh general terms you know like my work
in the obama white house at the united
nations
and
i think i was inspired in many ways by
my dad he's
as i said he's working in some of the
most
inaccessible scientific spaces that
exist like theoretical theoretical
physics right yeah quantum nobody's
quantum mechanics nobody understands i
don't understand any of this stuff right
um
and he has made a career in addition to
being a brilliant
scientist and
made incredible discoveries he's made a
career out of translating physics to
general audiences
um so back in the day when you know this
is before the days of corsair and
whatnot which of course you know he's
joined all those trains but he he went
online and all of his lectures were on
itunes for the longest time
and yeah because they used to have the
itunes itunes yeah exactly and they made
their way around the world
um we're streamed
millions and millions and millions of
times i don't even know what the numbers
are but i remember thinking they were
wildly impressive for physics lectures
and one of my proudest moments as a
daughter is when i was at
um
actually at my at a my sister's
graduation uh she was also at yale with
me and my dad was given
the teaching prize for all of yale wow
which i don't think had ever been given
to a natural scientist let alone a
physicist
well here's the low-hanging fruit joke
incredible that he did that where is his
podcast he needs to come on the show
i think no he needs his own podcast
that's hilarious well here's what you're
going to do you're going to have him on
your show he's going to crush it right
yeah and then
and then it's going to be so popular
that like malcolm gladwell will be like
we need to create a show yeah we'll call
it 0-60 yeah and it'll be getting people
up to speed on really hard um physics
concepts it's all worked out in a matter
of seconds it's all worked out so ideas
are born
um so anyway i love this notion of the
translation and i've always felt like
when it felt challenging for me you know
what dude your dad did it in the physics
domain and
made physics accessible to people you
would give general audience lectures all
the time when i was growing up right and
so i i felt like there were very few
boundaries and so i've actually worked
as a practitioner for
in of cognitive science for so long you
know so so walk us through this you're
at stanford you're you know in this fmri
lab yeah and you have the next
inflection point in the lifetime movie
occurs
yeah did we do a commercial break yet i
think people are getting bored no um but
i was in the fmri laboratory and
ooh i was not um not loving it my friend
which is a pretty
devastating
reality to confront when you've now
invested
what seven years or so into academia and
then plus undergrad right and so
i remember thinking oh crap um
i don't know what comes next i
i had no idea what a cognitive
neuroscience postdoc can go on to do
so i thought
well okay one you become a professor
which i'm realizing i don't want to do
after being in this windowless fmri
laboratory for ever and having no
social interactions with any of the
people whose brains i'm scanning
and then secondly
um
maybe i could be
uh
a general management consultant like
can i start that circuit so i call
my my trusted friend and mentor lori
santos and i tell her hey so um that
thing i've been doing forever and you
were like a really generous kind
charitable mentor to me i don't wanna do
it anymore sorry i'm going to try to
interview for all the general management
consultants consultancies
and she's like okay
before you do that
um
let's
talk for a second before i lose my
student who i've invested so much energy
and time into let's talk
and she shared this um
incredible story that i did not know
about how
the federal government was using
insights from my field from the field of
decision making which is where i
eventually landed in my postdoc economy
tversky work uh around judgments and
decisions and biases and was using
insights from that field to
help low-income kids get access to
school lunch so long story short
government offers this program
the national school lunch program
uh offers it to millions of kids but
millions of kids were still going hungry
every day at school and it's because
applications had not been submitted
successfully for the program and so when
they did a behavioral audit they
realized that there were at least two
barriers for parents enrolling their
kids
the first was that the
form was extremely burdensome to fill
out and so imagine you know you're
asking a single mom who's making
who's working three shifts to make ends
meet to fill out this extremely
complicated form that requires
referencing multiple tax documents and
oh by the way if you get something wrong
you can face a huge penalty and you have
to go to the post office on this day in
the middle of the day and get time off
of work and you have to make sure you
have postage stamps like
it was not practical um given given the
feasibility constraints that face a lot
of people's lives um
and then the other
one of the other barriers was stigma i
mean later on i learned in talking with
school principals and whatnot that a lot
of parents felt look i work really hard
for a living and
um
i don't want my kid relying on the
government
and so for that reason they weren't
signing their kids up for the program so
they ended up using a behavioral
economics insight known as the power of
the default
you're probably familiar with this and
all that happened is they changed the
program from an opt-in program to an
opt-out program so they use
administrative data they had collected
on these kids to automatically enroll
them in the school lunch program
and now parents would only have to take
an affirmative step
if they wanted to actively unenroll
their kids
from the program so now the onus has
changed right
and um you've reduced you've eliminated
stigma actually because everyone's now
just automatically enrolled in the
program right these these zero cost
changes that rely on
behavioral insights that have you know
tremendous real world ramifications if
they're just well thought through yeah
in this case 12 and a half million more
kids were now eating lunch at school
every day right it was unbelievable to
me and so
i had never i had read about the
theoretical potential of nudges and
behavioral science but to hear this
story told to me
um
was
it pulled on my emotional heartstrings
you know and i thought wow i kind of
want to be doing that stuff and so
the barrier was that
there was no job to apply for and i had
no connections in the political world i
mean as i'm just an academia forever
like no one political had ever even
crossed my radar but lori had heard uh
cass sunstein the co-author of the book
nudge
he's kind of one of the fathers of this
space and had worked for obama for four
years had heard him speak at a
conference and so she gave me his email
address
and i just sent him a cold email
and um
to our earlier point about insecurities
i wrote in my email because i was just i
was so
um
i was so anxious about him even thinking
that i thought that i could maybe ever
even have a slight chance
well also
the recurring theme being you're not
afraid to knock on doors yes not a fake
email being a version of that yeah and
so i wrote him and i said you know
because i have no public policy
experience i don't feel i've published
much of significance and i'm telling him
in this email i know you've worked with
obama and i wrote in parentheses i know
i'm not cool enough to work with the
likes of obama but if there's a local or
state government opportunity please let
me know i couldn't even bear
negotiating against yourself right out
of the gate and thankfully for me um i
mean one cass is married to samantha
powers so he's
he's used to having strong or he
believes in strong women um
and so he just ignored all that
insecurity and wrote back to me within
moments and said here's the president's
science advisor's email um here's his
deputies email
send them a note and let them know i
sent you along so every email by the way
the subject line is changing from one
important per one person who's more
important than me to the next person was
more important to me so the first email
to cast was recommendation from laurie
santos and then the second email to the
obama people was recommendation from
cass sunstein so i'm just using all
their names to try to get you know
generate some clout in a space where i
have zero
and um
i i mean i remember still so i was i was
i took a swimming actually when i was in
my 20s it was it's a very meditative
sport and it's absolutely i mean you
were in a very competitive space for me
it was always just recreational it's
still meditative though did you do it
while you were at stanford i did yeah in
their gorgeous olympic-sized pool where
the
home for oh my gosh what was your i'm
just curious to know what you're um
what was your stroke i'm just butterfly
butterfly okay that's pretty baller i
can't do butterfly keep going um so i
you have there's plenty of things that
you're that you're very good at don't
worry so i was
uh i think i was actually at the um i
was at the local ymca swimming because
the outdoor pools get me man it's too
cold um and so i was biking home and i
stopped at a stoplight
and
i looked at my phone as one should not
do by the way public service
announcement and i see this email
response from him and i nearly fell off
my bike i mean i just couldn't believe
that the white house people were getting
back to me because i wrote you know cass
email and i sent the scientific email
and then this guy writes back tom who
ends up being my future boss and says
you know just so happens coincidentally
that i live in california and i actually
commute to dc for three out of four
weeks of every month and i happen to be
here this week and if you can come to my
house
like one and a half days from now you
can interview with me
and so
i'm pretty scared about this thing
because i don't know what a white house
interview is gonna look like and so i
spend the next 24 hours calling
everybody smart than i know in my entire
life and mining them for wisdom and
insight good student on what i could do
the good version of tracy flick is
coming out
and so i call everyone i and i'm like
what ideas would you have on policy yeah
like for what you would want to
translate from behavioral science into
policy
and um
i have to get like a business suit like
i just don't i mean as a postdoc who's
riding a bike everywhere i only have
athleisure and so i i go get um you know
business suit i have to borrow my
friend's car i don't even have a car to
drive to this guy's house and i show up
and it's not at all what i'm expecting
i'm expecting this like stiff government
bureaucrat and instead i come in and
there's like toys strewn everywhere and
he's got his turd on shot or like his
own shirt untucked and um it was like a
very
familiar cozy home um and you know his
family was super nice and warm so anyway
sit down with him and
don't forget there's no role i'm
interviewing for so my
the onus is on me to pitch him on the
idea of um
even
creating a new role for a behavioral
scientist right you have to present some
kind of value proposition that exactly
that would you know substantiate them
hiring you for something they haven't
even really thought of that's exactly
well said that's exactly right and so
i start talking about the different
ideas i have and at one point i talk
about how
the first lady
michelle obama's language for her let's
move initiative could be improved using
some insights from behavioral science
and his response to that is oh well yeah
i mean i know
uh the first lady and her chief of staff
so we can make that happen
right your head's exploded what yeah i
mean again i was i was in the uh you
know ivory tower so to speak where in my
in my world ideas went to die and
suddenly this guy's telling me
i've got a translation system for you in
the form of you actually working in the
federal government and actually getting
to apply all these insights that are in
your head or out in the field and out in
research into measurable improvements in
people's lives and this is happening
near the end of the first term yes so
this is actually weeks before
obama's second term election
um so
i i think it was like in yeah maybe
early october or something and so i
remember at the end of the conversation
which was so much fun by the way like i
went there so nervous and then all of a
sudden it just felt like this extremely
fun you know kid in a candy shop talking
about all these fun ideas and did he
give you the job though how did it yeah
so it was very confusing at the end he
said well i'd love to keep in touch and
i was like
okay is that like
don't call me i'll call you situation
like i enjoyed our chat talked to you in
three years or i enjoyed our chat want
to give you a job so i kind of asked for
clarity who's like hey so let's just
unpack that for a second what exactly
does that mean um in hollywood that
means i'm never speaking to you again
and you will never get a phone call i'd
love to keep in touch that's some very
lukewarm uh feedback and so he said no
here's the deal
first of all no plans can be made
until we find out if obama wins his
re-election in a few weeks and i was
like yeah right oh totally fair by the
way at the time the biggest threat the
democrats faced was mitt romney so haha
jokes on us um if you fast forward um
and so
um yeah i wanted to work for obama not
romney just personal preference uh and
so we had to wait for that and then he
said i have to pitch the entire office
on creating this new role so that's
going to take me a little bit of time
you have to interview with the chief of
staff and the deputy chief of staff and
then third and this is where my west
wing visions kind of crumbled he was
like we're gonna just have to make sure
we can find you a desk and that's when i
realized actually the white house is
quite resource constrained and it really
just comes down to how many chairs and
desks are allowed in there with the fire
safety codes right yeah that might come
down to something as simple as they're
not thinking it was the the woman who
was hired for the general counsel's
office in west wing who ended up in the
basement you remember the spoiler room
some of the most important people in the
white house are working in the west wing
basement with no windows that's how you
know you really made it when there's no
there's no windows in sight
and so um
i mean i'm already waiting for that
election result but i'm really freaking
waiting for that election result in that
year in 2012 and
um
what was
again i can't believe i did this but i
ended up
breaking my lease in california and
signing a one-year lease in dc before i
even had a written job offer that's
pretty ballsy i sold everything but my
bike which i kept in
my aunt's garage and i was like i might
need this he must have given you a
decent amount of he gave me
enough verbal hope
and like maybe a light email here and
there but 100 i mean you don't get to
control the process right there's
security clearances like the fbi will
randomly call your sister
and be like so tell me about maya and so
you don't get to control all of it but i
really wanted this to happen sorry i
keep stepping on your environment to
interrupt but
it is a it is an extrapolation of the
theme of knocking on doors you're like
i'm just going to show up and i'm going
to you know if i if i've waited long
enough i'm going to go knock on the door
and manifest this make this thing happen
i that i had that visual in my mind
which is like i'm just going to be on
the white white house doorsteps and i'm
just going to wait until it happens and
i'm just going to show
how much
i want this job be friends with a
security guard outside the white house
yeah they won't let me just march in
there with good reason
um i grew up in dc so oh did you okay i
lived in lived in dupont circle it was
it was a lovely experience um and dc is
so charming so yeah so i moved to dc and
um
i mean that's when the real challenge
begins like i
every time you pivot
there's the
there's the path of getting you the
thing
and then there's coming to terms with
the fact that you now have now you have
it and you gotta you gotta make
something of it you have to show up for
it and i again had no public policy
experience and
uh i i felt like a fish out of water i
mean i had no idea how things worked
and i made it my goal
i so i i really benefited from
let me just say also at this point in
the conversation
mentors have been
a game changer for me in my life
i don't know if i would have if i would
have gotten to
have the kinds of experiences that i've
had
um
in the absence of people who took me
under their wing
and mama bared me yeah well talk a
little bit more about that i mean you
have
you live in rarefied air with respect to
mentors i mean it's perlman lori santos
like incredible human beings but for the
average person who is looking to level
up and realizes or recognizes on some
level that they could benefit from
having a mentor like how do you think
about that i'm sure
people young people reach out to you
they want you to be their mentor yeah so
this is the interesting thing about
mentors which is
i never
i never entered
um a relationship
hoping for a mentor on the other end
it was always a very organic process i
said with lori that when i met her i was
so inspired by her i just wanted to like
bring her close you know
and um
i never
now we talk a lot about having mentors
that's like a formal category like a
role that people play in your life and i
just never saw things through that lens
like i never thought of perlman as like
a mentor it's like pearlman's my teacher
yeah um
but
i think because i'm so curious about
human beings and i think because i
always prioritize the interpersonal
relationship above all else
it they naturally lent themselves to
friendships
and that's actually how i had mentors
like
uh i'm thinking about
tom my boss who taught me so much um
he became a fast friend for me and i
don't think a lot of people approach
that relationship in the same way they
were like this is a boss direct report
relationship and granted that's
sometimes how things happen everyone has
their own degree of comfort in in
blurring the distinctions between
um you know work and just real-life
relationships for me it's always been a
very blurry line i'm friends with a lot
of the people that i work with because
it's just more enjoyable to live my life
this way yeah um but i think i i'm
effusive
about my
excitement about people and so i think
in turn friendships form you know and
friendships are a two-way street you're
contributing to the relationship i think
a lot of people look at mentorship
relationships as purely extractive like
i need to be with this person and i'm
going to pull out of them as much as i
can
and not understanding
the
you know the social psychological
component
of being in the shoes of the mentor like
what am i getting out of this that's
right
that's an excellent point i have not
thought about that even if you're young
and don't have experience you can still
you know bring something to the equation
that's gonna you know like sort of
nourish the mentor yeah and i think if
you think of that in terms of like more
more of a service-minded approach to it
you're in a better situation to actually
you know be on the receiving end of
whatever wisdom you're looking to to get
that's a great insight and i'm just
thinking back um to laurie telling me
that
um
she found my energy enthusiasm for
cognitive science really infectious when
i was an undergrad and that sustained
her through difficult days it makes her
feel good professor
you know you invariably have
a tough day with a paper rejection or a
tough student or you know you're
mentoring all these
students that are at times struggling
even psychologically and
um
i think absolutely that relationship is
very mutually beneficial
and you know now thinking back to the
perlman relationship i was telling you
like i
approach a lot of things with a hint of
irreverence and i'm sure
pearlman was very used to sycophantic
relationships just like people you know
bowing down to him everywhere he went
and maybe he found it refreshing that i
didn't do that you know and i just saw
him as a as my teacher and someone who i
obviously respected uh to the sky and
back but that i could have fun with too
and maybe there was a light that
lightness which we talked about earlier
something that he appreciated so
i really um
yeah i really appreciate that you said
that i think there has to be
bi-directional benefit and i still
remember we were organizing a team event
in dc
and i invited my boss to come along i
was like oh tom you should come along
and he actually made a passing comment
like
oh it's actually rare that i get invited
to these things because i think everyone
was like oh he's the fancy guy at the
top we shouldn't invite him to these
things and but he actually you know he
was separated from his family who were
all living in california so his social
life in dc was not exactly hopping and
he loved the opportunity to spend time
with all the fellow policy wonks you
know in the neighborhood so that was a
good reminder too that we can bring
things to the people who mentor us yeah
i think to put a button on the
mentorship uh discussion it's also
important to understand that that
mentorship
doesn't have to come in the form of
itzhak perlman or lori santos
we tend to think that the only
mentors of value are the fancy people
who have written best-selling books or
who are famous or whatnot and i think
most people are surrounded
by people that have some kind of wisdom
that
like you said earlier like people want
to help right and if you come to it with
the right spirit
um
i think you'll you'll i think that i
think mentors abound more than people
recognize i'll tell you
one of my greatest mentors in my in my
daily life is
uh
the guy who does fitness training with
me his name's matt
and i met him several years ago and just
to give you a quick backstory i have a
history of
inflammation and a lot of injury and
kind of chronic pain that i've had to
work through over the years and try to
unpack and
every time i tried to work with a
personal trainer it would end in some
sort of disaster either i'd get terribly
hurt or
um something bad would happen and just
or they would go too strong too fast and
not understand my body and
matt
is the first person i'd ever met in my
life who showed
an unbelievable amount of patience
uh towards me i'm not kidding when i say
those first like few months we were
doing chest press with no weights in my
hands okay that's the level this guy is
like you know six two
um like very strong but this is not the
normal workout he's used to doing with
his clients like he's a hit instructor
and um
there was like a calm and
wisdom and peace and compassion
in his approach
that
blew me away
and has gotten me to a point where i
mean i've exceeded every dream goal i
could ever have had for myself where i
have a consistent strength training
workout that i do every other day that
i've been able to do for years now and i
had never before in my life been able to
do that without getting injured or
having some horrible debilitating pain
that would last forever and matt
took me under his wing
and figured out my body
alongside me like he was like an exp he
was like a scientist trying to figure
out like okay how do her biceps respond
to this motion you know he's looking at
that level and
it it made such a huge difference and so
i consider him one of my
biggest mentors in life in terms of
someone who's had a profound impact on
my well-being and my psychology and my
sense of self i'm still not strong
enough to like lift my bag into the
overhead compartment so i'm working on
that still need to ask for help but i'm
like
you know orders of magnitude stronger
than i ever was before and that's an
amazingly empowering feeling to have
sure
shout out to matt love matt fuller
matt fuller yeah um
what's up matt what's up matt lots of
love for you here today
um all right so you get the job at the
white house i'm envisioning
you're walking through the west wing
doing a walk and talk with josh lyman
he's taking you down to the basement to
show you your office where you discover
i've got a briefcase in my hands oh you
do right like you're probably possibly
overdressed josh hasn't slept in three
days you're bright-eyed and ready to go
only to discover you have no budget
there's no plan uh there's no road map
for what you're supposed to do here and
here you are sitting at your desk
and it's just you and you yeah and here
you're like okay well now what now what
yeah okay so
um so first of all on the over dress
piece my nickname in the white house was
sneakers
and because that was because i always
chose comfort in ergonomics over looking
good so i would wear i would wear
you have to wear business on top but i
would always be wearing sneakers until i
had some really important meeting in
which i'd flip into actually i did that
with you here too right it came with
sandals and then more of these nicer
shoes but better for the walk and talk
yeah yeah totally right to have some
comfort um okay so i get to the white
house and um
i learned some very
valuable pieces of wisdom from my boss
tom who
had the
um
had a lot of institutional knowledge
because he had spent eight years in the
clinton administration had left during
bush and then came back for another
eight years of obama so i was catching
him four years into that stint
and what he told me is that
he had spent so much time
as an individual contributor if you will
while he was in clinton clinton's
administration and that
when bush came into power it was as
though he had built this elaborate sand
castle on the beach for
eight years and then one big wave came
and just
destroyed the entire apparatus right
welcome to washington right
so his advice to me was
maya you can try to have as much impact
on an individual level as you can
however my advice to you would be
you want to leave
you want to leave a blueprint
for this work in parts of government
that aren't susceptible to leadership
changes or political changes
that that don't fall prey to this
you know
these political four-year cycle exactly
and so
he knew my dreams of being you know a
practitioner of behavioral science and
then i quickly got into my head after
that conversation
i think i want to build a team of
behavioral scientists that can operate
in a
bipartisan part of government and their
day-to-day job can be to translate
behavioral science
into policy as a matter of course
and importantly again it's not going to
be in the white house if we build it in
the white house then i know it's going
to disappear as soon as i leave um or as
soon as this administration ends you've
got to find those really boring corners
of the internet where they're where
where the lifers are hold up right
from the vicissitudes of
of the political cycle that's exactly
right and that's what i did so i i
you know coming in though i had no
budget and i had no mandate and um the
president wasn't exactly saying at the
time like there shall be a nudge team he
didn't even know who i was right and so
i had to
approach building this team completely
differently than one would if they did
have that high level mandate which was i
started on the ground
i talk about door knocking i probably
knocked on 300 doors in that first year
every person that i could possibly meet
with i would sit down with and tell them
about the skills that
um the skill set that i had and what
insights behavioral science could bring
to bear on the problems they were
already trying to solve
and i was just so eagerly trying to get
any government agencies to collaborate
with me and just get some early wins on
the board right all right well before we
dig into that a little bit further
when you look at tech for example
they're very comfortable with
this landscape in which you are expert
because these platforms are built upon
behavioral insights like how do you
remove all the friction to get the
person to click on the thing you want
them to click yeah all the way down to
the color palette and you know the the
way that the
you know the the the button looks like
all of that kind of stuff like there's
so much money in science that goes into
all of that like startup culture tech
culture
is completely about that
government not so much not at all so and
the incentives are not there because you
know when you're talking about trying to
pitch these people who are you know in a
different part of government um and have
been there for a very long time you
being a bright-eyed young person coming
in saying i'm going to do this new thing
like what's in it for them like they're
they have their little way of doing
things and it's about not rocking the
boat and anybody on the wrist you just
become a pain in the ass to everybody
100 i was everyone's pain in the ass in
that first year for sure um and
the only way i was going to succeed is
if i inspired organic interest in my
government colleagues because nobody had
to say yes to me in fact most people
wanted to say no to me i got more no's
that year than
any human being
i think it's gotten i mean the number of
people
where maybe there's an old modicum of
interest that it wouldn't go anywhere or
they showed no interest off the bat like
it was uh
like
there isn't a lot to gain for them yes
absolutely and like what if our
a b test reveals that their program
isn't as effective as i thought then
there's a liability involved so they
were taking a risk in partnering with me
with very little upside and i was aware
of this
and so i had to get pretty clever about
the tactics that i used to try and align
incentives
um
to
create an incentive structure where they
had
maybe at least not more to gain than to
lose but at least
even right
um
and so
and i and i also was faced with this
question early on which is um what is my
order of operations here right because i
don't have a budget and i don't have a
mandate so there's one world in which
i wrote elegant policy proposals and
drafted them up and tried to keep
pitching them to senior leaders and like
at some point could someone just sign
off and give me a few head count so that
was one version of the world
the other version of the world was to
reverse engineer that where
you do the opposite you start by
actually just getting some work done
showing
proof of concept
that this methodology works and can have
a positive impact
and um you just get your your feet wet
and you just get the job done
and i very quickly learned that the only
way that this was gonna succeed is if i
did the latter nobody was waiting around
with resources for my proposal to get
you know land on their desk for them to
sign right that was never gonna happen
and so
in that first year i you know eventually
was able to get a few government
agencies to say yes
and um one of them was the department of
veterans affairs they
were trying to get vets to sign up for
a
uh employment and educational benefit
that they were entitled to upon leaving
their time in the military
and we worked with them to try to
convince them that our
techniques could be helpful to them in
boosting participation rates similar to
the school lunch program not enough
that's for signing up for this even
though that transition from military to
civilian life is so fraught with so many
challenges and so it can be so helpful
to them to have these resources
but they were very budget constrained
and they only had one email to work with
and we changed one word in the email we
told we simply reminded veterans that
they had earned the benefit through
their times and service
time and service rather than eligibility
yeah and that that one word change led
to a nine percent increase in access to
the the veterans program
and and they threw a pizza party was the
first time they'd ever run an av test
you know we were most of the time that
my colleague and i were spending working
with them on this was spent just
building the technological apparatus to
run an email a b test which didn't even
exist and so that was part of my mandate
was bringing experimental methods not
just behavioral science to the table
um
but it was really really hard work
for every one of those wins
i swear there were 50 things that were
in the fire that never went anywhere
because it seems so simple right like
how hard can this be like change this
word you'll get a better result so not
my broader point just being like these
these tiny little tweaks that have zero
cost when you're when you're up when
you're when you're implementing them
at the highest levels of government with
respect to giant programs
absolutely end up saving billions of
dollars benefiting millions of people
and and so the results end up being like
really huge for these small things
absolutely and um
as huge as the results are is the effort
that goes into actually convincing all
of the relevant people
everyone at every level of government to
say change one word
change one word
and then sometimes we had much bigger
changes right program design um the
structure of defaults things like that
and so
it was really hard work but in that
first year year and a half um we were
able to just get a few points on the
board enough that
um
you know caught the
attention of the president's office and
we ended up having
a briefing with president obama in the
oval this was in early 2015 and i was
able to share with him
work that we had actually done like you
know here's the before and here's the
after and um oh my gosh it was such an
exciting and energizing meeting for all
kinds of reasons including that he's
just remarkably charming um but also
because
it was the first time
that
someone was acknowledging the existence
of this very makeshift team that i've
been pulling together through all these
creative hiring codes and whatnot and
he called it the social and behavioral
sciences team which is the name that
i've given right and he called he
thought of us as an actual entity that
existed and it didn't exist anywhere
other than in the impact we were having
we weren't in any clauses in any
documents like anywhere it wasn't a
thing we were just a group that i was
pulling together and so
having him say in that moment like you
are a real team and i value your team's
work um
was such a satisfying moment
yeah and in that in the fall of that
year um i think because of this initial
briefing
he ended up signing an executive order
that made my team a permanent part of
government and that was that's the key
so that that prevents the sand castle
from getting washed yes exactly and the
team
uh they're called the office of
evaluation science they still live in
the general service administration
they're still running amazing trials and
doing great work in a very bipartisan
fashion across the government yeah
continue through the trump
administration
although it didn't find its way back
into the white house i disbanded the
white house component on my way out the
door yeah whatever was still there i was
like ah
no i don't want any of this
would they be used in any way
um that's anything other than positive
so i just kind of didn't didn't renew
that charter right talk to me about
obama a little bit though sure you know
what is that
you know you hear these stories he's so
charismatic he's the person who makes
you feel like a million bucks yeah he's
completely attuned to you when you're in
his presence and all of that like what
is that magic
i i i was taken aback by it so yeah it's
real um i remember the night before so
interesting experience with this
briefing in the oval because
i was both
leading the meeting as the lead of the
team but i was also
helping to organize the meeting behind
the scenes by writing the president's
talking points for the meeting so
um you know i had my meta yeah i was
very met i was like and here's what you
should say to the team about this result
with the department of defense and
here's the work that we did so it's so
funny right to be both um a participant
and then also part of the team that's
helping potus you know enter the meeting
so
i was pulling together all the briefing
docs of all the wins that we had had and
and and our historical work and and
giving him some general talking points
and then
they asked for bios of all the members
of the team so i was curating the bios
and
it was alphabetical order so
i made sure it was in alphabetical order
um and so i was somewhere you know
farther towards the end
and
i remember pulling the bio together and
thinking you know there's that line at
the end about how used to be a violinist
and i studied with pearlman like that
doesn't really seem relevant to
my current role as a policy person i
should probably take that out for this
very formal briefing talk
and then i thought you know what he's
not gonna have time to read this anyway
who cares so i just keep it keep kept it
in
he opens the door the next day
to the oval and the first thing that
comes out of his mouth is oh my gosh
maya he studied with my buddy itsak
he played at my inauguration along with
yo-yo ma blah blah blah blah blah it's
like talk about making
one of your random staffers feel like a
million and a half bucks in that moment
he either took the time to read the
briefing doc which i actually believe he
did and he was just that studious that
he did do all of his homework all the
time i'm sure he did and or someone told
him about this and either way i don't
care what system was in play behind the
scenes
um the thoughtfulness you know we worked
so hard in that administration every
single one of us just was like
hauling
every minute of every day for those four
or eight years in the case of my
colleagues who worked for the two terms
and
to feel valued
for our full story in life you know um
it was wonderful um and so i instantly i
was just like the meeting could end
right now and i'm good you know
and so and then also just um
it's just such like a we just had a
jokey rapport you know
um
is it the kind of thing where you would
see him in the hallways then from time
to time like in in my like mind or
trying to envision like the real life
experience of like working in the in the
west wing yeah
uh not that many people are seeing the
president day-to-day i'm sorry to say um
but we were grateful whenever we had the
opportunity to
i'll say that but of course i mean his
actual like the really legitimate senior
advisors were like regularly in the mix
um with the president but i i certainly
wasn't um so in the other thing that was
so wonderful about this meeting is that
um
he was so engaged with the material
like you learn later all the things that
were on the president's plate that day
including national you know concerns
around national security and whatnot and
the fact that he was able to be laser
focused on our team for the entirety of
that meeting was astonishing that's the
gift and the job yeah no exactly i
remember at one point um he said to me
kind of cheekily he's like maya can we
get your team on congress like can you
guys just like fix what's going on over
there and i remember saying you know
with all due respect mr president we we
try and take on projects that are
difficult not impossible
um and so
yeah he was just um he was so engaged
and he
he made it very clear by the end you
know if you run into any obstacles i i
feel like he knew
that up until this point i'd been like
the lonely person i obviously had my
teammates but i was still top of the
hill being like hello listen to me
everybody can you please think
behavioral science is important
and he knew that if he could lend some
of that gravitas that he has towards my
cause it could be very effective yeah
and so helping you know at the end he
you know he's joking like you got my
number right any pr any problems anyone
gives you you just let me know you call
me directly um so he's a huge supporter
of the of the incredible
so how do you sign the executive order
which is amazing yeah i mean how did
that come into being the executive order
so
it's it's it's equivalent to a juilliard
moment there's no executive order and
then you just kind of create a draft one
day and you start circulating it and
there's a lot of resistance and you just
keep plugging and plugging and plugging
and one day the top of the document gets
changed to say executive order and um
yeah for the longest time actually uh
i think there was a feeling that like
behavioral science isn't sexy enough to
get executive order treatment um but my
point was well that's exactly the point
is that it should as you were saying
this some of this stuff just feels so
obvious this is just good government
practice and often times it is very low
cost
light touch interventions that can be
make or break for families everywhere
and so i think that's what helps
solidify the argument which is this is
this is what it means to just engage in
best practices as we run this massive
entity which is the federal government
a while back you you let slip with this
phrase behavioral economics but
i'm not sure i understand exactly what
that is
yeah so
there's a lot of umbrella terms that are
used in this space so i think maybe the
broadest one is just behavioral science
which is essentially the study of the
human condition behavioral economics
technically i guess on a definitional
level is just blending insights from
psychology with insights from economics
to have a more robust understanding of
how humans operate in different settings
i see the idea being that we're not
logical actors that were prone to these
emotional states and these defaults that
that lead us to make decisions that on
paper it looks like we wouldn't
otherwise
yeah and i mean
there are some philosophical
disagreements about what is logical i
mean it is actually logical sometimes
for a human to act on their emotional
states and so um
there's questions about that but i think
that's exactly right it's it's that um
there's a lot of hidden surprising
factors that influence our decisions and
our judgments outside of our conscious
awareness i think one of the most
illustrative examples of this is
um in the context of voting we like to
think that we will just vote for the
candidate we'd most like to see elected
into office that feels pretty
straightforward um but there's research
from texas showing that the order in
which the candidates names appear on the
ballot has an outsized influence on
voter behavior so if your if your
candidate's name is listed first that
candidate will receive a 10 percentage
point boost in boat share relative to if
they're listed last and obviously this
is in low information environments of
course if you're dealing with a national
election probably those ordering effects
are going to be a lot less relevant or
important
um
but i feel like
uh
when we know that when we know that we
as humans have this first in inline bias
it can lead us to design more equitable
solutions right to design policy
accordingly and
what's happened is now that now we
randomize the order in which candidates
names appear in a lot of places in a lot
of election contexts and that helps make
things fair overall so the reason i'm so
fascinated by this field is that when we
learn about it when we uncover insights
in turn we can become smarter in
correcting for those biases and solving
for them in the dna of how we design
policies and programs what are some of
the initiatives you would have liked to
have seen
uh happen when you were at the white
house that didn't happen or got no's but
you feel like we're good ideas that's a
great question so one of the projects i
was most passionate about about just
came to a an abrupt end um
my team and i started working on the
ground in flint michigan and with our
colleagues there during the lead and
water crisis and um initially we were
working in collaboration with
white house offices and also with the
environmental protection agency to make
sure that
safe water information was getting uh
into the hands of flint residents
but then when we visited the ground
and we actually went there and we talked
to
heads of churches and heads of local
ymcas and just people who are leading
the troops um
we learned that
the challenges
went so far back and that in in many
ways the lead and water crisis was a
symptom of a much bigger crisis which
was
decades of disenfranchisement and
systemic racism
and
people of color in the community feeling
like they had no voice and
rightly feeling like they were betrayed
by their government and and
consistently lied to
and so when you recognize that
you realize that the problem you're
solving for is in part water in the
short term of course you need to make
sure you don't poison an entire
generation which is what was happening
but it was trust
and
that introduced a whole set of
interesting
questions in the psychological domain
which is
how does a community
rebuild trust when they don't have good
reason to trust their government and
um
you can imagine how erosive that is
right and
this would play out even the decisions
we made around
the way that we are getting this water
safety information in the hands of flint
residents i remember so
uh
we think a lot about who the messenger
is um in this field right so what we've
learned from research is that sometimes
it's as important to consider
what the message is as who or who it is
who's delivering the message as what the
message itself is
and
um
i think naturally our instinct is to go
to the environmental protection agency
right like they are the leading
authority figures in when it comes to
environmental safety and so they should
be the ones delivering this message to
people on the ground
but then rich you think about the
backdrop here right which is that flint
residents have been lied to
for years by their locals they had been
doing its job they wouldn't be in that
situation to begin with or their local
their local government had let them down
and you could absolutely imagine that
that would um
translate to the federal government like
the glo your your feelings about
government
aren't boxed into oh i don't trust my
whatever my mayor or my whatever no you
just have a general feeling sometimes
towards whether the government is an
entity you can trust or not and
um there was no reason that they should
trust the government so what ended up
happening is that the
um i mean the local epa which was a
fantastic group of people to work with
i'm not sure that they were the ones who
were behind all the deception but um the
ones at least i came into contact work
with were fantastic they organized a
canvassing effort on the ground
in which they recruited trusted members
of the community
to deliver these information packets to
people
and um so we're talking
heads of churches
heads of the red cross members of the
ymca people that you're running into
as part of your day-to-day life oh my
kid goes to
you know
baseball practice with your kid i see
you every week i have reason to trust
you so those folks would go
door to door knocking and saying hi i
comma
trusted member of your community can
vouch for the information that's in this
flyer and that's very important when
misinformation and disinformation is on
the run right and you actually have
trust of people who can deliver these
messages so
um i was really sad i remember um so
that program was discontinued yeah it
was an effort i i mean gosh this is so
painful so i'd gone to flint
and then
the trump the election the 2016 election
happened
and i actually went back to flint
shortly after
and you could
see um
[Music]
you could see how traumatized people
were by this leadership change
like they already felt
that they were not getting the support
they needed and now it was like
is it are we gonna get anything are we
gonna get negative
support
are we
what like what is what does the future
hold that was so that was so sad to be
there knowing that
there wasn't a future
where we could help them
it's so crazy through that route it was
really hard just persist
in flint yeah yeah i know and and it's
going to be a problem for a long time so
i just
uh i remember knowing in that last
in that in that trip right after the
election like
oh this is kind of our goodbye
trip and we've gotten to know a lot of
these folks on a personal level and
developed beautiful friendships with
them you know and heard about their
grandkids and you know their role as the
head of a church or whatnot and so it
was pretty heartbreaking to see that
come to an end yeah well extrapolating
on that idea of of leveraging
cognitive science to
engender trust where that trust is
broken
scaling that up to
the the broader kind of
national
declining trust in institutions like
what does behavioral science say about
how we might address that do you have
thoughts on that like it's sort of this
epidemic right now that we're dealing
with where people just don't trust
uh institutions in general or that trust
is at
i don't know if it's at an all-time low
but it's at a at a low that is feels
unprecedented at least in my life yeah
one of my favorite insights from
behavioral science in the area of trust
building is around what's called
operational transparency
and it refers to the idea that when we
pull the curtain back
and we just let people in on what's
happening behind the scenes whether in
terms of what constitutes our decision
making process um why we chose x over y
the messiness behind the scenes i think
my instinct is the leader of my team is
to protect people from all the mess it's
like oh my job is to protect you but
actually
um it's kind of counterintuitive to
learn that that can be let me tell you
about buildings yeah towards building
trust to shelter people too much from
that process and so
there was a really interesting study
um run by some harvard psychologists uh
with the city of boston in which people
were complaining about various
challenges around the city so broken
stoplights broken stop signs potholes in
the ground and they're like when is this
stuff going to get fixed like we got to
keep living our lives here in boston
and
what the city did is they created a
virtual map in which they simply id'd
that all these problems were happening
and they showed where those problems
were
and then they had um these little
progress
meters right where you could actually
see that like oh this road sign you know
could maybe get fixed on thursday or at
least it's next in line and
even though the speed with which the
problems were going to be fixed was
unlikely to change the mere transparency
into the process was extremely assistive
in building trust and in this case the
study showed i believe that um
it led people to be more civically
minded they were more interested in
participating in their government as a
result and
i mean i saw this as a
as a regular of
uh i don't know if you're aware of pizza
tracker you're probably not because
you're mr health nut so anyway but i do
know your caribbean's occasionally
you're talking about some kind of social
media campaign where they were like
transparent about no no no it's actually
just a pizza tracker where when you
place your order
um
you can see where it is along the way
sort of like uber or something like that
yeah it's like it's like oh sarah just
put your pizza in the oven and like the
pizza's gonna come out now and now the
toppings now they're doing a quality
check on it um i wish i could say that
i'm reporting this on behalf of you
you're so emotionally engaged with it
yeah it's coming out of the oven
and so when i'm frustrated like where's
my damn pizza it's been so i feel like
it's been so long
what i and then your imagination is
thinking exactly they're not doing
anything
are they and then they are and then
you're like oh i should actually be a
lot nicer in the situation because the
pizza's on its way and you should be
patient and even though again the time
frame which i was going to get my pizza
has not changed i feel more trust that
things are happening behind the scenes
because you can see it happen because
you can see it happening
exactly it is common sense but but it's
transparency
it requires a level of comfort with
vulnerability and and it feels like a
political liability right
when in truth it engenders trust and
people respond positively to it you know
brene brown you get on her podcast she
talks about this all day long yeah but
it feels like the curve is steep in
terms of getting people to really
understand and start practicing that but
you know when you were telling the
domino story i was thinking of the many
examples of companies on twitter when
they screw up and they just they they're
just here's what happened here's exactly
where they send an email to their thing
and they're like here's what's going on
and here's what we're trying to do to
fix it that that breeds loyalty
and then people feel connected to that
because they weren't lied to and i think
uh you know as we become more
digitally savvy
our radar for [ __ ] becomes more
finely attuned and we can see the
[ __ ] coming further and further away
and i think that means that whether it's
corporations or government entities have
to shoulder that that responsibility for
transparency in a way that maybe they
haven't had to historically and young
people won't tolerate it they demand a
level of transparency that
you know people my age you probably
don't think about that much there was an
interesting study run where um in the
beginning of a brainstorming session one
group was asked to share something they
were proud of and another group was
asked to share uh something an
embarrassing story so like you know 100
vulnerability you're sharing something
you are actively embarrassed by
and when they measured the productivity
of the brainstorming sessions after the
fact the embarrassing session the
embarrassing story group outperformed uh
the proud of group because they get all
that out of the way and then they feel
liberated to share other dumb ideas yeah
and it creates a more open space i think
it was that not only
were the was the magnitude of the
magnitude of ideas increased but also
the diversity of ideas like the range
that they covered and so
it's it's not even that it like feels
good sometimes to share it can affect
productivity and outputs in in pretty
powerful ways yeah so if you were the
czar of behavioral insights for
america or whatever or corporate america
or government
i feel like that's mission number one
right like getting people comfortable
with transparency yeah and i think uh
just reminding people that when you do
admit to weakness when you admit to
struggling
um
it can build a lot of um you can build a
lot of credibility and you can help
people i mean that's the thing that i've
seen
in my approach to leadership especially
in the last two years when there's been
so much loss worldwide and
we've all
navigated um our own losses you know
over the last two years and
are grieving in some cases just lives we
used to have that we don't have anymore
whatever it is
everyone has been changed in some way by
covid right yeah and um
in many ways i saw
i saw that bring out the best in people
when it came to their willingness to
share
so on a personal level i remember
in the beginning of quarantine my
husband and i we we have to work with a
surrogate in order to have a baby and
um we had uh
we had a successful pregnancy and then a
pregnancy loss so we lost our surrogate
miscarried and we were devastated and i
didn't share it um publicly with the
team so this was in like february of
2020 that this happened
and then fast forward um
a year and a bit a year and a few months
and
our surrogate's now pregnant for the
second time and i'm feeling super
optimistic and she's actually pregnant
with identical twin girls jimmy and i
are like wow can't believe this finally
happened after years of
fertility
um stuff and trying to find a surrogate
and we found a beloved surrogate who
lives in arkansas we love her name's
haley and we we thought the stars are
finally lining and this is going to
happen
and then
she miscarries again um on exactly the
same day as the time before and
we just got unlucky haley's healthy our
embryos were um
tested and normal and it turns out she
just had an autoimmune immune response
to her embryos her body was treating her
embryos as kind of foreign
material
and i was um
i was beyond devastated i was so
torn up by the second loss and
i didn't know how to process it and um
had to navigate my own emotions about
all of it and we were
all at home and not having the social
supports we're used to sure there was at
some point probably was delta at that
time that was that was up there's always
one um
and i remember
i think it was that night
i wrote a note to my entire team at work
saying
[Music]
i'm suffering
and i'm in pain and this happened to my
husband and me and our surrogate and
i'm gonna be offline for a while but i
wanted you all to know what happened um
because i
want you to feel less alone if something
tragic happens in your life um
and
i heard from so many people you know um
who
shared with me that that helped them
feel more comfortable sharing when they
had something bad happen you know that
it was modeling that kind of behavior
and we haven't talked about the podcast
yet but i i turned to my own show in
that moment of grief which was so
surprising for me i
i mean i can be an open book about
certain things but this felt so deeply
personal and i never expected to share
it with anyone outside of my
immediate family and close friends like
it was just not a thing that felt
comfortable for me and yet
when i was in the throes of this change
and felt so overwhelmed by it
i realized that okay i have this show
called a slight change of plans in which
i'm inviting all these people to come on
and talk with such vulnerability about
how they navigated their slight change
of plans and while i'm the throes of
production
the host of a slight change of plans has
her own
[ __ ] storm thrown her way
and doesn't know how to manage it i felt
like i needed the show in that moment
and so
i actually turned the mics and had my
producer interview me
about my experience with loss and um
it was so therapeutic to do and
you know the episode's called maya's
slight change of plans you know it's
never expected that that would ever be
an episode um
and
i think one thing that we know
that's positive that can emerge from
loss and grief is meaning making and
purpose-making and
i can't count the number of emails that
i've gotten from people all over the
world who have navigated losses in this
domain or losses in any other domain who
felt emotionally connected to me because
i was willing to share my story with
them
and that overwhelms me to this day like
i get a little emotional thinking about
the impact that it's had
on so many people and
i feel like that's maybe i never really
thought about this before i feel like
that's probably been the greatest area
of growth for me on a personal level is
a willingness to show
when i'm
suffering and to process things out loud
maybe the podcast has helped me get
there but i think it's also just growing
up and maturing and realizing
what's the point of keeping it all in up
here no it doesn't do well it doesn't do
well when it leaves there on uh you know
grief is best shared and it does
engender a level of you know emotional
connection and trust and for you being
the host of this podcast where the very
theme of it is how we navigate hardships
and what we do in the face of life
throwing curveballs at us had you not
shared that it would ring unauthentic to
who you are so i think it was really
important you know as well as courageous
to do that but i'm not surprised at the
response you know i i'm
somebody who's been in recovery for a
very long time and you know has the
gift of of being exposed to communities
on the daily who
who share their pain and their
vulnerability and their you know the
terrible things that they've done
with such a um
a level of courage and comfort at the
same time
and there's something
very unique and special about that that
makes you feel connected to those people
and and trusting of them and also
empowered to do the same
yourself right like had i not born
witness to thousands and thousands of
people you know standing up in front of
groups big and small to share their
their
their their deepest shame and their most
embarrassing moments
with
without
any more shame attached to it is
is incredibly powerful in terms of like
how you think about the
the things that you're ashamed of that
you're hiding from the world that you're
afraid to share and i think the more
that we get comfortable doing it
like you said you get all these emails
from people like that was a self to them
and makes them feel like they can have a
different relationship with their own
pain and together we grow and i think
there's something really beautiful about
that and and
and i think you know being a member of
that community has made me a more
has made me a better podcast host
because
i am
more empathetic to the people that i'm
sitting across from because i've been
exposed to so many you know versions of
individual pain and
and mishap in life
that it's
it's impossible for me to judge
someone's lived experience yeah yeah
i think that's
i mean that's really powerfully said and
i think one thing that has
surprised me and heartened me
when it comes to making a slight change
of plans is how universal our change
stories are
and how
the psychological strategies we use to
navigate change and the coping
mechanisms we use and the insights we
generate they seem to transcend
circumstances
and so
i think before making this podcast i
would have thought oh you know i'm
having someone who's in the throes of a
stage four cancer diagnosis the people
that this story is going to resonate the
most with are people who are going
through a cancer diagnosis but instead
i'm seeing fascinating crossover effects
that seem to align people along
psychology rather than circumstance so
um
a recent divorcee
shares how
the betrayal that one of my guests
shared in in getting a stage four cancer
diagnosis even though he had spent his
whole life trying to be to optimize for
his future and be a health nut
is a similar kind of betrayal that she
felt in her marriage um
in her marriage ending and um i i shared
with you that i shared my own story of
loss um and i heard from a woman who
lost her 21 year old son to an overdose
and she said
it was in hearing your story that i
finally found healing that i i
i saw
a new way
of thinking about my son's death
and um
[Music]
that has helped me so much you know and
those circumstances are wildly different
she lost a 21 year old son and yet
something about how i shared something
about
the way in which i psychologically
responded to this and
the realizations i had or the
reflections i had touched something in
her and and helped her and so i love
that
that we can learn from stories that
don't look like our own it means that we
have this infinite resource of wisdom
that we can tap into when we're
navigating change
of course and although someone's
wonderful life experience is so
different
as they say in recovery like the facts
of the experience you know don't pay
attention to the facts of the experience
look for like what you can identify with
and you know humans come in a variety of
archetypes and there are only so many
stories right the facts are infinite but
the themes are
less so right so there's something about
storytelling stories told authentically
and with honesty and vulnerability
that resonates so deeply with the human
psyche
that a non-fiction book can't like you
can write out all the facts here's what
here's how humans work and here's how
they undergo this and here's what you
need to do to work your way out of
whatever it is you're dealing with and
it's in one ear and not the other like
you can intellectualize this stuff
but short of making an emotional
connection with a version of your story
you're hard-pressed to you know find
that sense of peace and
and uh and hope i think that only can
come through storytelling and podcasting
is such a powerful medium for that and
you know i applaud you for you know
being very focused on this subject of
change and finding these amazing humans
through which you can you know share
these stories of transformation
that you know for your behavioral
scientist mind i'm sure create this like
map of meaning like how are you mapping
psychology like what are the what are
the you know similarities between these
stories from which you can extrapolate
certain truths that um can tell us uh
more about what it means to be human
yeah that's exactly right and a large
part of my motivation for starting a
slight change of plans is that
the science invariably will fall short
at some point you know it's not like in
the throes of grief you can open up some
book to page 78 oh there's my answer
instead um
in those moments we we sometimes do just
have to rely on the collective wisdom
from other
from other people's stories you know
it's like the wisdom is in people's
actual lived experiences and we can
derive strength from another strength
like i'm thinking about the episode you
did with your friend
who who was this health nut and you know
suffered this cancer diagnosis and
shares very openly and honestly
about what it has been like for him yeah
and what's been oh my gosh this
this has been
uh
such an uplifting thing too which is
seeing how listeners from all over the
world have like fallen in love with the
cast of characters that we've had on the
show so i had scott the the guy you're
talking about on the show last year i
think it was last summer
and um
he talks you know he's an early
30-something who
is probably like you in terms of your
fitness and healthcare
yeah
yeah so vegan intermittent fasting high
intensity interval training definitely
is not ordering dominoes
uh as
you are not as well um and i was
sufficiently shamed earlier when i
brought up that example but
um
and talking about your inflammation it's
like i we need to talk
yeah i know i should probably uh stop
with the cheese anyway um but also
cheese like makes my heart so happy so
there's a trade-off there
solution for that yeah the solution okay
oh wow this is so great okay i'll need
to get all your pro tips on this so
scott has done everything he possibly
can to try to optimize for the future
and then he gets this
in the middle of quarantine stage four
bone cancer diagnosis and
within weeks he has his right leg
amputated below the knee
he eventually has to get a vertebra
removed from his spine he has to get
surgery on his other leg uh part of his
femur was removed and he has 18
administrations of chemotherapy in texas
so he's upgrades his whole life okay
and there's a huge loss of identity
he's prided himself for so long on being
mr fit and so in addition to
losing um
so much of what he has in life and just
enduring so much physical pain i mean he
talks about it like the leg amp mutation
as being civil war pain
that's how he described it to me um he
says that
um
[Music]
on any given day he was more worried
about losing his six-pack than he was
about dying yeah i i appreciated that
honesty yeah
like just fessing up to his own vanity
exactly and being like it's not like
when you get a cancer diagnosis you
suddenly stop caring about all the
things you used to care about i'm still
scot
i still have
some values in my life my value system
and you know it doesn't all evaporate
in the face of some higher goal or
purpose right
and so um he's talking about these
identity shifts and is starting to learn
slowly over time
that maybe his identity is more
negotiable than he thought that's the
phrasing he used which really
touched me and
when i first interviewed him he was
about two-thirds of the way through his
treatment and
i
just kept hearing from listeners how's
scott doing how scott doing everyone to
know how house scott
and so um
i was able to invite him back on the
show just recently his episode aired
what a guy um his scans show no evidence
of cancer today which is amazing so
thrilled
and
it's not even an and it's a butt but
what's so fascinating about scott's
story is that
his change didn't end with the
completion of cancer treatment it's a
whole new set of challenges and
questions that are arising
um in his life some of which he's
finding
more challenging than the awfulness that
he endured during treatment
questions like
what does it live what does it mean to
live a full life like i was willing to
fight so hard for this life that i'm now
living right now
before he was just following doctor's
orders and it was very clear
what was expected of him what was
required of him people were defining his
life so even though some agency was
taken away from him
um
he knew
what it meant for any given day to be
successful
and now that was taken away from him
because now it's up to him to figure out
what it means to live a full life and
that's scary it's scary and
oh my gosh that second conversation just
blew me away i mean i
i still think
i i find myself even though i'm in the
interviews and the interviews will run
long sometimes you know like you're
you're you actually air the whole thing
right so we do
um edited produced episodes sometimes
the conversations run an hour and a half
so i'm in the interviews and we're
editing it down to about 30 or 40
minutes and so i'm hearing this tape
like so many times in the production
process probably like 14 or 15 times in
full by the time we get to the end and
that's not even including all the mini
sections i'm hearing
and yet
five months after an interview i'll just
be making a peanut butter sandwich
and some guess
profound line enters my head
and it hits me in this new way
because of the very specific thing that
i happen to be going through in my life
i hear their their words in my mind
differently i interpret their words
differently than i did the first
15 times around and so
so much of what scott shared with me
about his changing identity and how he
views
old scott versus new scott i mean it's
just it's a it's
a fascinating conversation that takes so
many philosophical turns
that
it's one of those episodes that i even
though i put out in the world i continue
to listen to like
i feel like i need a few times to digest
all of it um and so yeah anyway my
guests are just amazing i just feel like
i can go on no you've had tons of crap
people and we should point out that
apple named it the best podcast of 2021
that was amazing
when i got that call i was just like
first of all i felt like taylor swift at
the grammys
but when they said it was the best show
of the year um
i just couldn't believe it honestly um
because
but maybe that's part of it's like this
whole thing just was so organically
generated i never had dreams of being a
podcaster i never thought that i would
ever have a podcast and
um it was really just passion from day
in and day out and i i think that's in
part what people see in the show which
is
it is um
a host who's kind of on a personal
expedition to try to understand herself
and the world better sure and um
it just it's all come from
[Music]
uh
from just a very personal place you know
starting with my beautiful life as a
violinist and the changes i endured
during that time so it's kind of led to
this point but um
i've fallen in love with podcasting i
mean you've been at this for a lot
longer than i have um
i
i don't think there's anything i've ever
enjoyed so much
it's a pretty great gig i mean really
meet all these cool people look at you
i'm holding you hostage today getting
you asked all these questions for hours
and nights really incredible and it's
incredible to me
how when you're willing to share
yourself in a conversation people are
very willing to open themselves up
and share things you've never heard i i
love it when i go
this happened in three conversations i
had an interview with
tiffany haddish amanda knox and hillary
clinton oh and tommy caldwell the
professional rock climber uh who lost a
finger and yet is still one of the
greatest big wall climbers in the world
omg he would have figured out how to
play the violin with like four fingers
um so a few things i can't do yeah
exactly and i remember for all of those
interviews because these are relatively
public figures i had done so much
research on them read
every word they'd ever written listen to
every single interview they'd ever done
just like mine the archives and the
internet watched all the documentaries
around them so i went into those
interviews
thinking i had a relatively good command
of their lives and their big inflection
moments
and each of those guests proved me wrong
the moment they revealed to me as
actually being the turning point for
them was not the moment that i would
have thought based on what i'd heard
from the news and what i'd read in
articles about them
and
that's really fun and fascinating when
your guest shows up and is like nope
everyone's got it wrong yeah that's
actually not no it's correct it's not
the moment it's great for me
what i loved about the tommy one is
this idea that we were talking about
earlier between
you know the loss of the violin and
realizing that it wasn't the violin for
you but it was the ability to connect
with people
and discovering through your
conversation with tommy that
that climbing is the is is merely the
vehicle for him to access these flow
states and it's really about like how
can i experience flow states in my life
and climbing is is just the device for
that exactly i mean when i when i heard
about tommy's story for those listeners
who don't know he was held hostage in
kyrgyzstan
um nearly died of hypothermia and
starvation ended up pushing his captor
off of a cliff
right at the very end and um
i would have thought for sure that that
moment was the defining moment for him
and it turns out what he
the the thing that really stayed with
him through that whole experience was
unlocking a state of mind that was novel
for him that he experienced
profound mental acuity when he was on
the brink of death basically and
he said he's been chasing those flow
states ever since through his climbing
and has
very occasionally achieved that kind of
acuity
and those are the kinds of things that
unless you dig really deep
you're not going to get those insights
right and
so i felt we were we were such a perfect
host
guest duo because me the cognitive
scientist coming in having studied flow
and then tommy being like flow is my jam
yeah it just yeah it felt like there was
a lot of magic in that conversation he's
also just like the nicest human being i
also love it when i meet
people who i really admire and
they just turn out to be incredibly kind
talk about humility i mean you can't get
tommy to say one
positive word about himself it's it's
pathological almost um but he is oh he's
so kind and so open and generous and um
yeah he's a friend now which is
wonderful yeah that's cool climbers are
salt of the earth
as a general rule um i want to i want to
kind of close things out and finish this
up with some more general thoughts on on
change and perhaps what you've learned
about change not just as a cognitive
scientist but as a podcast host and the
work that you're doing you know i know
you're in the private sector now through
the experiences that you've had over the
course of of of your career and in
thinking about that because
you know as i said at the outset of this
transformation personal change is really
at the core of this show and
in my own life i've had these many
pivots you know swimmer to alcoholic
lawyer to athlete and athlete uh author
podcaster and you know who knows what's
next um navigating you know setbacks and
obstacles along the way and confusion
about you know who the person is that i
want to become and trying to align my
behavior with my values it's all very
ephemeral and confusing when you're in
the midst of it right totally it feels
like elementary when we map it out and
talk about it and
i think
that can
if not handled the right way can land on
people like a burden because it feels
like well if i just did these things
then i would figure out what these
people have figured out and life doesn't
really work like that so i wanted to
leave people with maybe some takeaways
or actionable tools or or just
a means by which to think about change
in their own life that that can have
like a practical positive impact
so i think you know i'm just listening
to you and scott talk and you talk about
how we're really bad cognitive
forecasters and i think that absolutely
applies to how we
internalize change current day change
future change
um
one fallacy that i've i've seen humans
fall prey to through just making the
show i didn't have this insight before i
started interviewing guests is that
we tend to believe that when there is
a change that's introduced to our life
either
wanted or unwanted
that
it happens in a vacuum it happens in
this isolated way where
i am maya the exact same person
almost walking through a magic mirror
but with that one little change that one
tweak made in my life
and
that's just not how human beings work
where these really rich complex
ecosystems where change in one part of
our lives naturally has lots of
spillover effects into other parts of
our lives
and i think the lesson i've learned from
that is we need to be we need to
approach change with a profound amount
of humility
because we simply can't anticipate all
of the ways in which the change will
affect us so we got scott on the one
hand whose worst nightmare has happened
and then he actually finds a lot of
positive growth that happens as a result
he basically said his his happiness is
at a level that it was before his
diagnosis he says he achieved um
like happiness he said he said the um
the
thermostat has prevailed
the uh happiness thermostat yeah and so
um he said he basically achieved the
same levels that the the bad moments
were of course worse
um and bad but the good moments were
just as good which is surprising and he
also felt like
he
um
had built more empathy and he was
developing into a slightly more flexible
human being and that
being as rigid as he was before maybe he
wasn't the best version of scott right
so he felt he had he saw considerable
growth in himself and then i talked to
people who willed a change who thought
they were going to have
an unequivocally positive thing happened
to them um
uh there's this one woman i interviewed
elna who went on a mission to lose
weight and she lost weight very
unhealthily but she lost i think over
100 pounds in a very short amount of
time and for a while she thought she was
living her dream life until she realized
that that weight loss was having all
kinds of negative impacts on her
personality
interestingly she she became um
more self-conscious as a result she kind
of was buying into this
part of society that had been unsavory
to her before but was now seducing her
into it and um she felt she became a
worse person and that she worked less
hard for things and um
she suddenly realized that there was
this complication
that and she literally you know i talked
about the metaphorical mirror she had
the the physical mirror she she was
motivated initially to lose his weight
when she was at an amusement park with
her family and she
sees herself in one of those
illusion mirrors
and so she imagined herself stepping
through it and being thin elna
and did not appreciate all the other
ways in which her life would change as a
result and so
as a as a result of hearing these kinds
of stories across the board where
change didn't unfold in exactly the way
that people expected or there was a
complication around the change so
another one of my favorite episodes is
with a guy named
morgan
when he was a
when he was in his 20s he ended up
having uh gender reassignment surgery to
align his body with his true gender
identity
uh which was um which was male
and initially he's intoxicated by
feelings of liberation from his female
body you know he's enjoying the
the base in his voice and enjoying the
growing muscles and finally feels
comfortable in his body and is feeling
so liberated
and then
a few months later
is confronted with
the realities of living as a black man
in society when he gets pulled over by
the cops in
his grandmother's affluent neighborhood
and so
it's just always more complicated
because we we maybe we will maybe the
wisest among us in humanity
will
uncode exactly how we ourselves will
respond to a change
but to have a grasp on how the world
will change its response to us how the
world will interact with us differently
that's untenable right
it's unattainable to have that level of
insight it's also something we have no
control over right and we have no
control in the context of change like
thinking about the very few things that
you can control and being at peace with
the fact that there are externalities
that are well beyond your control i feel
like the the healthier your appreciation
for that lack of control or the more
acceptance you have around that
um the happier ultimately you're going
to be and and perhaps the more engaged
with the change that you're trying to
create in your life i think that's right
and you've hit on another big theme in
the podcast which is we do love falling
prey to this illusion of control and it
comes up time and time again in
different interviews that i have with
folks who
wanted to believe that they were in
control and when this when their slight
change of plans happens it's a sobering
reminder that control is an illusion and
they have to grapple with that yeah as
much as the change god's got other plans
what's the adage like you know tell god
your point if you want to hear god laugh
tell them your plans
um that's exactly yeah it's it's uh
you know again that goes back to like a
recovery thing this idea of surrender
and surrender not being like a giving up
but just developing an appreciation for
the fact that your
like
instinct to try to hold on tightly to
outcomes is
is really an engine for suffering yeah
yeah and i think there's also a
distinction between like a lot of the
stories on your show are about how
people
use the word change but i i think if
it's more
more appropriately thought of as like
adaptation like when something happens
outside of your control like how do you
adapt to that versus i'm going to change
my life and i'm going to take these
steps and move in this direction like
those are two i'm sure those live in two
different parts of the brain yeah
how do you think about that difference
is that
i mean
it's
i don't know if it's living in two
different parts of the brain but i think
they are
competing forces and just a continual
tension
that just seems to define existence
right
and
there's no right answer to where you
should fall right
but and i think that that dynamic
changes over time and depending on the
specific change circumstances
um that you're in but
yeah it's a challenge um one thing i
wanted to touch on before we close out
is uh
is something we were talking about
briefly before the podcast started
this idea of
of the present-minded
present-minded movement like being
present-minded being a movement right
now and
and and the kind of irony uh
of that in that you know the reality of
most people is that we're living in the
past or we're living in the future we're
obsessing on things that that actually
aren't real while we're talking about
being present yeah
so spending too much time in the past or
the future
can be very unproductive when it kind of
races away from you and
you enter
a state of like anxious rumination so
i absolutely am pro
redirecting attention to the present
when you're in those moments but i don't
want people to fail to appreciate this
incredibly remarkable singular human
ability we have
to
spend time in the past and the future
not all species have this ability and
it is actually remarkable that you can
be sitting here at this table right
and
your mind can be somewhere completely
different
it can be imagining things about the
future it can be coming up with new
ideas it can be
marveling at an experience in the past
it can be dissecting an experience in
the past that gives you insight into how
you might have been better how you could
be better
it gives you important signals into
ways to improve and
i just feel like there's so much
emphasis on the present right now
that we're starting to maybe move too
far in that direction and i just want a
little bit more balance because there's
a lot of utility we can derive from
spending time in the past or the future
a very clear example is some people's
presence sucks
and i want to give them a respite from
that
like if you're if you're if you're
present if your presence sucks right if
you're scott in the throes of cancer
treatment
and you want to spend all your damn time
in the past or the future have at it
please let's minimize human suffering
and that's not even considering again
the virtues of spending time in those
two spaces because they can be
enlightening thinking about the future
can help you figure out what it is you
want in life how you want to spend your
time like it allows your imagination to
run wild right um and thinking
reflecting on the past can make you a
more thoughtful
introspective person right who's
actually engaging in in self-improvement
sure and so yeah to be sure
you know recalling
episodes from the past that can make you
make better decisions or
or be a better human being in the
present moment like there's certainly
benefits to that i think to be fair that
the thrust of it is
aimed at the fact that
we actually spend almost no time in the
present moment and even if we give lip
service to it very few of us are
actually present at any given moment
and the fact that we're constantly
obsessing over
things in the past or or or what might
happen in the future
that
that casting of attention generally is
on negative things for a lot of people
and that obsession on negative past
occurrences or you know the disastrous
thing that's about to happen you know
are going to create a negative reality
for you or or force you to make a bad
decision or you know so just awareness
around that i feel like that's a much
bigger problem than the fact that like
we're telling people that you know what
we're shaming people about about being
present so here here's my thought on
that which is first of all we're 100 on
the same page so my initial caveat was
that the minute it turns you know
ruminative obsessive
uh negative in that way then of course
we want to redirect our attention to the
present what i'm trying to help
alleviate is a meta anxiety when people
find themselves thinking about the past
or the future because it's not always a
bad thing
even if it even if you're not deriving
utility from it your mind's just
wandering to some episode in the past
that is
a feature of the human experience that
is rich and textured and interesting
and so like if you do find yourself
thinking about the past and it's a
neutral experience it's not good or bad
it's just neutral
lean into it a little bit and marvel at
your brain's ability to do that thing so
that's all i'm doing trying to remove
this metal layer of like damn it why
can't i spend i'm not able to spend why
won't keep that right feeding yourself
yeah beating yourself up for not buying
in i'm not like
you know i mean clearly i sound like i'm
a lobbyist for the past and the future
but i just feel like there we should
maybe not be so hard on ourselves you're
goddamn right i'm not present i'm
thinking about this other thing what do
you have to say about it yeah i mean
here i am just envisioning my future
meal i'm just saying that the escapism
can sometimes be really assistive for
people um and also i think just
an incredible
thing that our minds can do and i don't
want it to get too bad a wrap
um because i think it's actually a gift
we've been given by virtue of being
human that we can spend time in these
different temporal places fair enough
fair enough
um well let's end it there i could go on
like i said i have this outline that
goes on forever i can talk to you for
hours and hours and hours um this is
really fun that was really fun yeah how
do you feel so flowy do you feel okay oh
yeah i mean we did pretty good didn't
work definitely a marathon your
interviews but i love it
they go as long as i feel like they
should go i know that's great this one
went the appropriate time for what i
wanted to talk to you about this is
really fun appreciate you for being so
thoughtful in your questioning and
clearly doing so much research
my life in my show if you if people want
to learn more about
everything that you're yeah so
finally on social media that's the thing
that only happens
you follow no people and you have like
very few posts so i was like oh you you
were smart and we're not on social media
i was never i got rid of all this
podcast yeah i'm sure a bunch of people
told you you have to be on now yeah and
i think i'm in this like
um
i'm in this wonderful space where
like fans of the show just get so
excited and we get to communicate
through this platform and i love hearing
what listeners have to say right
questions they have you're in the halo
period yeah i'm in the halo period
exactly i'm like wow social media
exactly so i'm hoping to exit before
that that that's that shift happens if
at all um but i met dr maya shunker so
um it's d-r-m-a-y-a-s-h-a-n-k-a-r
on instagram on instagram and um the
show is a slight change of plans it's
available for free anywhere you get your
your podcast all the places all the
places and it's just
um a total love project of mine i think
you can see it in my face that i just
love the show and i could talk about it
forever but i really hope people love
the show because
um i i've fallen in love with the whole
process of podcasting yeah well the
show's great you're you're you have a
natural talent for doing it so everybody
check out the podcast i love it you won
that crazy award for good reason
and uh come back and talk to me again
sometime yes i would love to thanks so
much for having me
cool peace
[Music]
you